streaming is going to start now
and i'd like to welcome everybody to the
extraordinary
infrastructure meeting 22nd of march 22
before we
take in the first submitter i just want
to remind all
members that
can we keep the questions to the subject
matter
that the submitter talks about that's
according to
section 15 3 of standing orders
so if we can keep keep to the questions
about what he's what the submitter has
written or what they've spoken that'd be
great
thanks
right we're ready for the first
submitter
if we have one
um apologies for this the first
uh is going to be jonathan berton
thompson from the nazi nz heavy all age
industry
and uh the first time is actually gonna
be eight
eight thirty that's why i communicated
um yesterday to the governance team so
apologies it will be a bit of
time
um so yeah 8 30 for the first person to
be heard okay
thanks i can't i can try
no it's all good
it's we'll just no thanks
okay
right we'll just uh i don't think we
need to adjourn the meeting but um
yeah we might stop the live stream if
that's okay
thank you
we stopped the live stream
now yeah we will
okay
just on 9 30.
right
i'm gonna reconvene the meeting and uh
meal just when
you're ready for the first submitter
we're ready to go
welcome jonathan
good morning hello jonathan um hello
right the floor is yours literally
okay thank you very much yeah
um so that's my name's jonathan banner
thompson and i'm chief executive of the
heavy haulage association based here in
wellington i'm just working from the
home office today you can probably tell
um
okay so thank you for the opportunity to
um firstly um submit some comments in
writing but then also to just to
discuss a few items um that in
particular
would like to highlight um
so
just so you know who we are so we're a
small association but of um
transport operators that specialize in
oversized freight um
so this is a freight that's larger than
high productivity and is more focused
around basically any trucker you see
going down the road with oversize on the
front so
if you think
house movers
excavators diggers
large forestry equipment
and even in your area i understand
there's more talk about wind farms so
wind farm components all get shifted by
members of my association some of them
are resident in your area um other ones
come through and work within the
boundary of your city limits so
so that's where we are coming from
um so
so the consultation highlighted a number
of different issues and i just want to
reinforce and perhaps talk on building
points um
so
just looking at the speed limit
principles
so in our view you've got quite a large
range of different potential speed
limits that you've identified as being
useful in the area um
and
so
from our perspective
we think um simple is better
so
in my experience um
in my sector
when we transport large those down the
road safety is of key importance to us
so i do need to say that that is one of
the prime things that we're interested
in um
and so what i have found is that when
you put
controls conditions and that sort of
thing on on the transport of a large
load the simpler the rules the easier to
understand the easier to gain compliance
from road operators in my case members
but in the case of speed limits from
those people using the roads so it seems
like there's quite a lot of different
speed limits that could potentially be
used
and we really just i know that you've
done a lot of work on this constant a
lot of work on this to come up with a
hierarchy that you have but we think
that the 30 50 70 90 hierarchy is
perhaps another way to look at it um
starting with the 90 kilometer an hour
ones for those which are
suitable for those types of roads uh we
that that's the normal maximum limit for
heavy trucks so that makes a good sense
to utilize that speed limit
in many areas around the country we've
seen 30 kilometers an hour for central
speed limits so cbd type situations and
so we think that one could be useful
looking at your plans a lot of the the
residential areas are retaining at 50
and so you've got a large proportion of
the limits at 50. so really
um so to us
you know the intermediate one could be
the 70 kilometer an hour so that's why
we've suggested the 30 50 70 90. people
are used to the 50 in the residential
areas the 90s suits the heavy traffic
the 30 and the cbd is a good safe speed
limit so there's just something just for
you guys to um to think about um
and so the other side to all these
different potential speed limits
is all the signage that can be involved
in signing these um
these different roads so as you're going
down an arterial route then if you go
off to a side road then that could
potentially be a different
speed limit
and that could lead to a proliferation
of of speed limits and in fact um
if a road user happens to miss that then
do they actually know or remember or
recall what speed limit
and from an over dimension load
perspective we often transport loads of
the full width of the road and wider
and so we've been concerned about the
large number of signs that could
potentially be on the sides of the roads
which could
provide a restriction for over dimension
loads
yes it's possible to put them all in
sockets
and that sort of thing but it still
leads to a lot of signage that needs to
be removed and replaced every time
um
so
just keeping an eye on time so the other
area that i really like to highlight is
the sealed and unsealed rural roads so
there's quite a
network of heavy or vehicle roads that
are used by heavy vehicles and in
particular in oversized loads and in my
submission i had a link to
the some maps that nzta produced a
number of years ago
not not 100 up today but still they
provide a good um useful guide to those
routes around the cbd and in the rural
areas that provide
for oversized loads that if you like
steer those types of loads the heavy
loads away from the residential and the
cbd area and to us it would incentivize
transport operators to use those routes
if they either were at the current speed
perhaps 90
so yeah i mean you'd have to look at a
bit more fine grained approach to
individual roads but really we'd like to
see that type of um
regime sort of applied to those roads so
and i've got a list of them there
and
um with some additional ones that aren't
on the maps
so
i think i may have had my five minutes
so i don't want to overrun on this but
if i'm happy to talk a little bit more
about our submission if you'd like me to
but apart from that i'm happy to take
questions okay thanks jonathan
right um
we're going to open up for questions
from councillors do we have any
questions for jonathan
it doesn't seem to be any questions
jonathan if you did have a couple
more things to say um you're most
welcome
okay all right um
listen the um
the school zone so listen we absolutely
support the use of those um
school zone um i guess restricted speed
areas for where they're uh you know
before and after school and that sort of
thing and i note that you've got a
hierarchy that's got the urban ones and
the rural ones differentiated
i would just like to encourage the
council to use not a not like a
one-size-fits-all sort of approach so if
it's in the in the rural area then does
it always have to be there
um i
need to have a look at those individual
school areas to see whether there is
actually a lot of traffic um or people
actually on entering onto an exchange on
the roads for each individual school
area um
so and yes sir so you've got the the as
you identify idea of the um 30 versus 20
when you're going past a school bus so
it would be good to see that resolved i
understand that that's probably a um a
larger issue for the nzta perhaps you
set the rules around this but i guess it
does make it
potentially
more difficult to comply with if you've
got differing speed limits
which are similar within it within the
same area
okay thanks thanks very much jonathan
okay thank you
thanks a lot okay
um look before we move to the next
submitter um just a bit of
the agenda i've skipped over and that is
apologies so i am actually going to move
that
the apologies of council rabbit
councillor
sorry not council rabbit a councillor
kit
uh punya coote
and
lateness for counselor crackit i'll move
those anyway second those
thank you councillor sopra i'll put that
all those in favor
thank you sorry about that
right we moved to the next submitter
which is paul hurley
oh paul
would you like to come up and
sit at the table here
yes you can remove your mask to speak
oh good morning everyone uh should you
want to sit down and use the microphone
just bring the microphone
close up to you just just
just just thanks nigel
there we go okay well good morning
um
i'd like to
support the whole idea of road to zero
reducing the speed limits as the in the
document
over time to 40
um on most roads in
town
and 30
in the areas that are actually
highlighted that's in windsor and going
through south city
but also we do have various crossings
for pedestrians
in particular along the
garden walkway
now when you look at the otapuni garden
walkway it actually is intersected by a
number of streets and i think it's
appropriate in those cases to have a
lower speed limit now the whole thing
about a lower speed limit is that
it's safer we all know that from
statistics um it's um also something
that we have to think of the future with
electric vehicles
coming on stream very quickly now
it's quite dangerous for people who are
crossing the road um because they're
quiet you know so the car coming along
at 50 that you can't hear is a whole lot
more dangerous than
a vehicle coming at you
silently at 40
and you think the driver he's going to
be able to stop
at 40 but 50 well
we might have
quite a few more accidents
i would like to
do a physical demonstration
this is 50k
40k
i i take it the one on the left is the
one on your right is intact
not completely
intact but
this one is is a real mess right so mass
and velocity yes yeah yeah
words great but i think when we see it
in reality this isn't just an egg it's
someone's head
so we have to take it really seriously
now the problem is it's going to be a
huge huge push back from people that
love their cars
and i think we should
be ready for that and start
perhaps suggesting to the government
that we start a campaign of being calm
and cheerful is better than being the
big hero with the big powerful car and
to possibly introduce legislation
reducing the power of cars i mean what's
the use of
a car capable of going
180 200 when the maximum speed limit's
only 100 at the moment
seems bizarre it's almost like the the
gun debate isn't it that we've got these
big powerful cars it's all part of a big
big
ego trip and so perhaps the council
could lead the charge on that and
suggest that we do start just toning it
down a little bit
and over time we can turn it right down
because the car should be just for
transport not some big ego trip with
lots of power under the bonnet and all
that kind of nonsense
okay are you finished now for your
submission
okay thank thank you
well um i'm going to open up now uh
council ludlow first
morning paul thanks for your submission
um
understand what you're saying about the
otapuni garden walkway but do you think
the number of people that are making use
of it are sufficient
to
to say that we need to bring in a 30
kilometer
speed
limit for one block
right along the the length of it
this is a short little answer because
you could say no at the moment but if
you did introduce a
lower speed limit and signs and
encouragement then more people would
actually use that
thank you
counselor sopher
thank you mr hurley i noticed that you
had put in your submission about
encouraging community ride sharing
so did you have any anything you wanted
to add to that particular point about
community ride sharing or
more use of public transport
um yeah when when it comes to community
ride sharing we're not talking about
taxis and uber and stuff like that this
is a matter of reaching out to your
neighbor and saying oh
why don't we um ride together to work or
your work mates and stuff like that and
what council could do is offer free
parking for cars that arrive at the
parking building with a passenger on
board
thank you
for the questions
thank you
paul that's um
councillor skel do you want to report on
the eggs
at the end of the afternoon
it's worth you all have a close look at
the two eggs to be honest right now
that's a good it's good um
the uh i must say the demo wasn't as
impressive as at home at home it was
like the the 51 was
really leaking yellow out and the other
one i
don't know
this time okay would you like those eggs
disposed off here
i'm gonna make an omelette with them
stop it
oh well well it came on my bike so yeah
it's a bit awkward
i just wonder
i could well
russell is our egg disposable expert
we could have a parade of the eggs
that's right
thank you very much
no mirrors
used in the demonstration i appreciate
that good work sir
we love you thank you
so paul if you'd like to follow um mr
pearson he'll take it through that way
okay
next submitter is desmond
welcome to the
meeting
yep you can take that off to talk
they're awful things aren't they
have a seat oh have a seat and that's
the microphone in front of you
away you go
um
i saw it's been a while since i filled
out my submission i sort of forgot what
i said in it really but anyway it's
about the speed limit thing
um
i don't see the point in changing
anything i think it's more not the
council's job
to educate people how to drive
like
the the speeds are like other values
know the tara so you know i'm going the
back way and all that sort of stuff and
they've dropped the lit speed limit on
there and that's
you know
average but yeah um
before that there's no big accidents
nothing really major that's caused by
speed
most of the accidents if you you know if
you google the four major
reasons for accidents speed
might be one of them but it's not the
road speed it's speeding drivers if you
drop the limits on speed it's not going
to stop these speeding drivers they're
going to go fast no matter what the
limits are
so to me
it's a worthless exercise the limits are
there
and they seem to be working for the
majority of the people
you know if you drop them down like
you're talking about 10ks in town and
all that sort of stuff
the speed is regulated by the amount of
traffic on the road like
you go through town or rush hour you're
probably going to do 10ks anyway just
because of the that's what the traffic's
doing
if you go through there at 2 o'clock in
the morning when there's nobody there
you can probably set off 40 50 k's quite
safely because there's nobody there and
so
to make a big song and dance about
changing the limits
is wasting everybody's time and your
money you know i mean it must cost a
fortune to change all the signs and all
that sort of stuff that's basically all
i wanted to say
okay right now we're gonna um we can
have questions now awesome
okay do we have questions
well you've got off
real easy there
oh no no here we go council lewis easy
to understand submission yeah
just through the chair asked do you
think there should be more law
enforcement checks on on the speeding
limits
the reason i say i was going down bay
road yesterday at the normal with the
new restricteds
and um
persons that was coming up behind me
probably doing about 100 120 wasn't me
was it
just good and
screaming down the en ended up having to
put brakes up when they came up to the
main road um
into that restricted zone another person
was basically tailgating me all the way
yeah yeah like i think option
i'll get the same thing like you know um
even before the speed limit was
introduced you know like the otaru
straight or you know the airport
straight
you know like
i hardly ever sit on 100k but i get
people screaming past me for the sake of
100 meters
like quite often you see the speed
camera
thing there and all that but that
doesn't actually deter anybody because
by the time they get the ticket it's too
late
um but yeah like
more police like as police time like i
know that you guys don't control the
police or anything like that you might
be able to recommend
you know there's a lot of speeding
drivers here can we put somebody there
and all that sort of stuff but
they're on the same boat as everybody
else they're limited by budget and
manpower but i i totally agree that's
the way to you know that's the way to
stop it you know stop
speeding ticket here because not only
this speed issue perhaps i think you may
agree it's the narrowness of the road it
doesn't take very much to er off to into
the grass verge and then yeah yeah major
accident but but once again that comes
down to education like um maybe it's too
easy to get a driver's license
yeah like when i was younger
you know sure the cars were a bit slow
and all that sort of stuff but
there's so many people i know on their
practical learners after 15 years sort
of thing
we nee you know like the education's not
there because that's where we go wrong
it's like people speak because they
think they can
they don't know any better like
i don't know how you do it but
yeah i don't know if that's a council
job or it's a
government's problem no it's no it's not
our job but you raise a valid point uh
the further questions
uh counselor sofa thank you i was
interested in your um
submission and you may have forgotten
because you didn't mention it um was i
ranting at putting no putting speed
bumps outside schools
yes like um i don't mean the little
short you know
bump but i'm sure in christchurch before
the earthquakes and all that and a lot
of schools they're quite wide speed
bumps like a path you know and you still
had to go up
over and down and that just slowed cars
down outside schools
and um we didn't have to change the
speed limit or anything like i know
there's school zones and all that sort
of stuff
but like just to reiterate about the
odatara one you go down that 70k street
straight in odata and there's a school
there
and you know they have crossings and all
that and the speed
restriction sign and all that
but like it doesn't take much to get
into daydream and you buzz past anything
hot there's a skull if you had like as
like a low speed bump you know
oh there's a speed bump slow down
you know like 150 meters before a school
150 me you know either side
bump bump
slow down
and that just takes it away from
everybody like
as a good reminder
thank you
is that sort of what you're thinking
thank you
now that's a valid point uh
further questions
okay well thank you here's one
shot guys
have a good one
yep thanks
the next one is on zoom
different order
jules are you there jules
hello
it seems to be frozen
oh yes
okay
look we're just a bit ahead of our
schedule so you're most welcome to start
if you're ready
that's all good um his council got out
the graphic
just wondering
it kind of looks like this
yes we have got that
okay
okay
we got to go yes we're good to go
thank you very much so
if you order
your worship and counsellors um called
jill's award takuwenga i am a health
provider at the public health unit of
the dhb and today i'm accompanied by
dennis burton professional lead public
health and we appreciate the opportunity
to speak to this oral hearing
the proposed icc speed limit principles
support the national strategy to address
road speed waka kaitahi nzta road to
zero
road safety status
safety strategy public health south
therefore supports all icc speed
reducing principles outlined in the
consultation
so what does this mean in relation to
the invercargill district speed review
enrolling in traffic by-law consultation
our submission supports the icc speed
limit principles to lower speeds on both
urban and rural roads outside schools
during
school drop-off and pick-up times and
then suburban shopping centres in the
city centre
in addition we recommend the speed limit
change within that one to three year
time frame
to allow for a concurrent public health
education program a public education
program alongside these speed limit
changes
this could be for example conversations
with commuters in the local community to
engage them
and understanding the importance of
reducing speed around schools wherever
children learn
we also recommend
traffic slowing road modifications are
implemented in the lower speed area so
that they naturally
make drivers inclined to slow
whether this be changes to the
streetscape such as narrowing or tree
lining or appropriate infrastructure so
that it is safer for tamariki to
cycle or walk to school
we recommend prominent school warning
signage such as electronics speed limit
signage by school
if studies have found these to be
effective
we commend the work of our rural schools
such as myra's bush school
community for their proactive measure in
having such electronic speed signs
installed at their rural school
traffic slowing modifications and
prominent
warning signage in both
urban and rural environments encourage
drivers to make decisions to reduce
speed and therefore drive to the
conditions
there is a wider opportunity here
our urban and city centre environments
have focused on cars during our
lifetimes
these speed limit principles could help
reclaim the streets of people
we recommend the human centered
framework of lucy saunders healthy
street indicators as a public health
lens in looking at the built environment
in relation to the speed review and also
to urban planning
and on the infographic the wheel
is
the 10 principles of
lucy's indicators
originally healthy streets was developed
in london but is now being used by
greater auckland
because it has a series of very specific
guidelines that are used to help improve
street design outcomes across 10 key
indicators and they're on the
infographic
every decision we make about our built
environment
however small
is an opportunity to deliver better
places for people to live and thereby
improve their health and safety
creating a healthy street will make it
safer and protect populations who use
active transport that can be at
particular risk on our roads
cyclists pedestrians wheelchair users
bush chair users
scooter users and people with different
abilities if we think of children a city
designed or 80 year olds those who are
learning to be independent but still
don't have good risk knowledge and
strategies to 80 year olds where they
might have
hearing visual or mobility issues
this would be a streetscape and city
designed for all
shade and shelter
places to sit and rest and things can
see and do
can create an environment for people to
connect
relax
and enjoy and it encourages people to
choose to walk and cycle
additional benefits are environmental
gains
clean air and not too noisy
and this helps to reduce pressure on
other parts of the transport system
public health staff encourages active
transport because more physical activity
creates a multitude of enormous health
benefits and this has been shown during
covert nineteen
health begins where we live
work learn and play
and the invicable city council like
other councils has an important role to
play in shaping our community to improve
the well-being of our residents and
visitors to the invercargill district
this offers a wider benefit to the
community from the proposed investment
in improving road safety
public health south is the principal
source of expert advice within the
southern district health board regarding
public health and well-being matters
we are eager to work in partnership to
develop strategies and policies that
will improve the health and wellbeing of
all people in invercargill
district thank you for your time and we
welcome any questions which you might
have
okay thanks janice
right we have about approximately three
and a half minutes for questions
um do we have questions
no janice and jules that seems you've
seemed to
not dragged out any questions so thank
you
for your submission
thank you thank you very much council
thank you
right now that takes us to
the next one and we have healthy
families and the way hope
and who who is speaking today
all of us
are you most welcome um to come up to
the that table there with the two no
this one right in front of yeah two
chairs and
we might nigel
and whoever is speaking can you can you
just drag the microphone
close to you
and if you can just introduce your name
first
thanks
a chairperson
welcome sir and
good morning everyone my name is joe
wakefield i'm the deputy chair for
waihoo
okay
call stella o'connor
from healthy families in vicardil
right who would like to go first i'd
like to start um so the waihopo runaka
and healthy families invercargill
support and lead communities to have
healthier and positive community
outcomes with the focus of wellbeing of
whanau and the places they spend their
time
the waihopo runaka and healthy families
invercargill support the council
creating speed limit principles to guide
its decisions in the future making roads
safer in the city and in rural areas so
that those using active transport people
walkers cyclists scooters and in cars
can move around and interact and connect
safely and easily
the healthy families invocable active
transport innovator has spent some time
understanding the needs and challenges
relating to accessing the miura
hakumarai on tremway road both now and
when the redevelopment is completed with
the intention of it being a cultural hub
for waihope invercargill
so today we are asking for two requests
related to the submission
and the first one is to move the 70k
sign so that the change of speed is
beyond the entrance
and the second request is for a pathway
to be implemented that goes directly to
the main entrance of the mirai
in the past we've had some discussion
with council roading team about
considering moving the speed limit
around the main entrance of the miura
mirai so this consultation is quite
timely
currently the entrance to the mirai is
in a 70k zone with the change of speed
from 50k to 70k several meters before
the mirai main entrance
and there is no footpath going up to the
mirai and this is concerning for a
number of reasons
cars are accelerating with the speed
change coming from west tramway road
passing entrance to the mirai if you can
imagine this you're driving
down tramway road
and you see a 70k sign before you what's
the first thing you do you start to
accelerate
and that is happening right at the
entrance of the mirai
there is no shed path for active
transport walkers go scooters cyclists
mobility scooters mums or prance into
the main entrance
which again creates an equitable unsafe
access and doesn't align with tikkana
for entering mri
there's already now a number of kamatawa
on scooters or who already come can only
come via a sealed road
and there are significant numbers of
school groups in rangatahi that visit
often by active transport so that's not
by car by walking or by bike
the placement of the current 70k sign
means that bus transport companies are
charging schools and community groups
for an extra zone price which is a
financial barrier to accessing our
city's cultural hub
so that means they are charging for a
50k zone and then for like
i think it's um 80 meters with a 70k
zone they charge an extra zone as well
future proofing the mirai redevelopment
there's obviously going to be an
expectation of a higher usage once it
becomes cultural cub cultural cup
hub sorry
and
development of a
we're looking to perhaps developing a
cultural connecting trial from the cbt
cbd to the new mirai
so there's been hickalys in the past
going to the mirai and there are these
areas where you can't actually walk
into the main entrance because there's
no footpath
and we all know there's also a new
housing development tipuawai which means
there will be more traffic in the area
[Music]
just want to say too that um
in the past and roy's been there since
83 and really nothing has been done
outside
outside that mariah or anything
and it's had a hell of a lot of people
going through that place and it's been a
feature for
for mirihiki uh for for waihulpe
and with the new one coming up and the
new build and all that is going to be a
lot lot a lot more busier
a place and it's going to be significant
to why hopefully as a mark
a landmark here on this
on this town
so these things are really really needed
as you all know no one wants to walk up
there on the side of the road by the
ditch then when they have a path
they want to be able to push a pram
they want to do all these things safely
i i guess for me it's about future
proofing
it's about making sure ensuring
that people using tramway road coming up
to the mirai but also
with the future um subdivision being
built beside the mirai shout actually
about providing
a safe
i guess
safety for all people or users
with the mirai itself
yeah i guess our visions going forward
as we're wanting to develop the mirai
further
in terms of being a hub for our
community so that includes people of all
ages so at the moment we do have coma
tour who are on scooters and having to
use the road in terms of accessing the
mirai for activities even though at the
moment our mirai is closed because of
redevelopment
but you know we have been concerned
about their safety in the past
having a footpath available will allow
access for for schools but for other
people to actually access
arrive without having to
use a car all the time okay so for me it
is about future proofing it's about
ensuring
all our whanau our community's safety
going forward i've seen cars drive down
there and are doing more than 70
kilometers per hour
you know and i guess with increase in
traffic coming out of the mirai in the
future once we reopen but also we have
to pull away next door the subdivision
of contractors but then once people move
into those internet subdivision and
build yeah start living there there is
going to be an increase in traffic both
on the road but also foot traffic
cyclists walkers et cetera so cheer up
everyone okay thank you chuck okay now
we've got uh roughly three minutes for
questions council lalo
thanks cheer marina thank you for the
submission
cyril
um can i ask if
you can estimate
over the past 40 years
the increase in the number of people
that have been going to the
oh marae fault
but uh yeah
like if you just imagine um
just
say for instance uh
but it takes up a whole lot of people
you know big time and you have a whole
lot of government officials things every
hui so i'd say
it's increased since since the time i've
been i was there in 1990
yeah
and it's really increased
from there to now by tenfold you know
like
the people that are coming up here and
using that area so not just the volumes
but also the frequency of the use of the
model yes and as the frequency has been
the last two years has gone down but
up to now yeah
thanks stella just on the the speed
limit that you talked about and you
talked about the the bus price zones
even if it was peeled back to
60 kilometers does that make a
difference
it's still a change in zone yeah so
we're asking for a
sign to be moved so there's they don't
have to have that financial barrier of
two zones
thank you
next year
thank you any other questions
can i just say one last time yes you've
still got time yes
i just want to say um we all came into
the in the city council building today
through the main entrance and past the
city's treasures tonga and it really
evokes an emotion it was a it's a
wonderful first impression and i don't
think you would ask community
dignitaries or visitors to walk in the
back door which is essentially what
we're asking people to do to the
miraculous
we want this would like to see the same
protocols
uh procedures tikkana
to be observed for the mirah kumarai
in other words the main interest to the
marine needs to be
as you come into this building the same
way
and i guess also too
just going back to
the question earlier before
you know in the future we're actually at
the moment engaging with horanga
tamariki and looking at potentially
hosting a home community home on our mri
sites we're also looking at a wider
community hub and talking to other
government departments and and possibly
having them be based up on mri as well
so there's a wider vision here that
we're looking at as well so it's going
to in terms of people volumes
coming up tomorrow in the future it's
going to increase compared to what it
has been in the past
there might even be a council meeting up
there one day yeah i'd love that first
one yeah and darren you talked about
the changes zone which may not be a
council thing it could be an nzta thing
i'm not sure about that but um
is it up to the
waihopo runaka to
make that contact with nzta or can we
see councilman um i think we would we
can raise that separately but not at
this submission thank you that has been
noted yeah
okay thank you stella cyril and joe
thank you
thank you
the next submitter is scheduled at 20
past
welcome alex
um
welcome john
how are we good can i take that off yes
you can take that off
and just pull the microphone up
you got the microphone in front of you
just like that one there yeah yep
perfect i'm not used to this sort of
thing
i'm up i'm a bit deaf so you have to
yell at me as well
waiting for new hearing aids
um
my turn to go
yep you may start um i don't know if
you've seen what i've written um
but
it might be a bit radical but my idea
one of the big things was
about the speed around schools
um it's been proposed that it'd be
30 kilometers an hour and my mantra does
that
um we have 20 kilometers an hour
around a school bus that's partly on the
side of the road
with something like only one or two or
three maybe kids getting on
whereas we have
at a school
three or four hundred kids sometimes
milling around
even when the school buses are parked
there um and we have at the moment fifty
kilometers an hour speed limit bastard
but
we're talking yeah the review is talking
of
30 kilometers an hour i'm i
feel that a whole thing should be that
we look at something uh be radical
become whole country should go to a
simple thing of
20 kilometers an hour
um around
wherever there are school children
mingled in that way like the schools
as in the same as the school bus part on
the side of the road we're going to have
it 20 kilometers an hour because it's a
danger for one child getting on or off a
bus that's going to be
well we've got 300 outside of school
um we've got the same issue in fact
worse
that that's my feeling
right we only have to have it at that
speed
at that
timings of sort of 8 30 to 9 15
then again
2 45 to 3 30 when we got that major
major
um
usage around those schools although we
still have
the same thing wherever a school bus has
parked anywhere around the community
at 20 kilometers an hour
um
think
you know that
we
actually could take a lead um not just
be the us
we in mcardle have this
and then
uh klutha had something else uh
dunedin have something else that
we've got time on our hands let's start
something that we can go
let's get this nationwide so that we
have got a
a simple thing and it will be in
everyone's mind at 20 kilometers an hour
sorry as
becomes the norm
um
i i also when i put in there i think it
was relating to
uh
roundabouts um of course
i have issues with lots of people come
on to roundabouts you've got one guy
doing 50 kilometers an hour another guy
doing 60 kilometers an hour uh various
wherever they are some people doing 10
kilometers an hour
again i go back to my thing of thinking
what's a safe speed around things
why don't we we can't with no reason why
we can't
have everything come on too i round
about at 20 kilometers an hour
um
whilst it's on the roundabout that's the
speed from something like say 50 meters
before a roundabout it's down to that
speed
20 or 30 meters around to the exit side
of it all crashing on the roundabouts
traveling at the same speed
uh makes things nice and simple um
maybe it's a bit out of the
thinking of some people or the sphere of
thinking but
again
i get back to my thing of
uh 20 kilometers an hour is actually
quite a safe speed uh i've done it
on a roundabout
at 20 kilometers an hour indicating your
intentions uh turning right or exiting
if you're doing much more than that
you're juggling with
turning the steering wheel
working an indicator
you
really are starting to put it outside of
the balance capability of some people in
um doing any more than about 20
kilometers an hour
um i i don't know i probably i could go
on without lots of other things of
uh
[Music]
speeds that you you know that the review
has in fact
um
uh
put in that's the the
material that we've got
um i live at odatara um
i
drive
the uh
from the roundabout at
tweed street tide sweep
um i mean two street boundaries
intersection two odata
uh i see
daily um
uh almost accidents uh or near missiles
i suppose we'll call them um
at the airport
have a new turn off um
and
um so again i put in my thing i think i
did anyway
that we look to extend while we've got
the chance to be looking at all these
things
extend the 50 kilometer an hour
uh speed limit from where it is at the
moment just past the roundabout on skid
street as we come
to a point just beyond the intersection
of
airport avenue
also
airport avenue being 50 kilometers an
hour as well all traffic coming from
odata will reduce from 100 kilometers
now to 50 kilometers an hour just before
that intersection
uh
all traffic coming from the airport
going to the airport is all doing 50
kilometers in there all during the same
speed makes things nice and easy for
merging
um there's
there's my thought with it
uh odata itself
nice new footpath on the south side of
the road um
well my traveling since it's been done
uh
i i would say that we need to look at 50
kilometers an hour throughout that whole
area from where where that is out to
the arizo river bridge as well that's
just looking at some of the things that
i've seen um that
while we've got doing this consultation
while we're looking at it it just throws
more uh food for thought i suppose we'll
put it okay no thank you for that look
that leaves us with a couple of minutes
for questions
um
yeah you have to yell at me
um
i don't usually yell unless i'm angry
um just a question really um
are you
positing the position that
any area around the school should be a
20k zone between 8 30 and 3 30 every day
yeah just just just on the school days
now yeah we have
our school days yeah yeah just on the
days when the schools operate
and i mean we have these
polls with the designers on them you
know they've got their
flashing lights on them to slow
everything
go to tell everybody they're in the area
so if we just in those areas for those
periods of times when you've got the
bulk of of the kids around
kids kids to me
often when they're at that going into
and out of school
their mind's only on that as opposed to
the traffic and i tend to think that
it's looking after them as far as that
goes yeah
i i couldn't agree more but um
irrespective of whether there is
buses using at that school oh yeah you
are proposing yeah yeah regardless of
when the bus was i'm just saying my
bathroom was that
if it's
if it's kids regardless of take the bus
away or if you have a bus there 20
kilometers an hour
deciding or said to be a safe speed
uh even if you take the bus away 20
kilometers an hour is still probably a
safe speed
thank you i just wanted to clarify that
the other thing that i want to clarify
that you um sort of just added towards
the end
is that
is it your position that this
density of population in the autarta
area that you've described is now such
that it would be more sensible for it to
be a 50k zone rather than as it is now i
i think so there's more people out there
i know clara
i i just look at the the and see that
the amount of also people that are
up and down the the cycle track the
walking track um
to me it's just just
i think it says in here something about
going to 60 kilometers an hour
the area is getting more and more people
in it and i think 50 is probably uh you
know a reasonably appropriate or eighth
more appropriate speed
and a more mixed use is that what i
understand it's a more mixed use area
now
more more walkers and bikers because of
the footpath and oh yeah all that sort
of thing yeah thank you okay thank you
right we
used our time up now
yep so thank you very much
thank you
oh i put that back on
okay
welcome jeffrey
you may take your mask off to speak
and there's a microphone just in front
of you if you just
pull that
up yeah
that's that's the yep if you just bring
that close to you like this yep that's
fantastic
so i'm on
yes
thank you yeah welcome jeffrey you may
start
thank you
my submission does not support the
proposal to impose a 40k speed limit on
most urban roads
and
i'll just run briefly through my
submission to give some of my reasons
i think it's
unnecessary and will have a very minimal
impact on crashes
um and simply because most of the
crashes that are caused by excessive
speed the drivers don't take any notice
of the speed limit
if they had done they wouldn't have been
traveling at excessive speed in the
first place
um
and it's possible that lowering the
speed limit
will contribute to more crashes because
people get frustrated and try and
overtake
and take risks
it also reducing the speed limit is
likely to inhibit the flow of traffic
and
in my view the focus should be on
using what's called evidence-based tools
i've discussed this below briefly
um to identify appropriate solutions
throughout the city
and the evidence-based tools i'm
referring to i've taken from the uh
nzta website and sort of that they as
you might know they have a campaign road
safety campaign and process
so
councils
review document states that
over the past 10 years has been 116
serious urban crashes
resulting in six
fatalities
88 of those crashes were not caused by
excessive speed
speed had only been a direct factor in
12 of those crashes
so and
the
review document states that even if all
road users followed the rules
fatalities and injuries would only
reduce by around
50 and 30 respectively
given these statistics
uh presumably apply to all accidents not
just the 12 caused by excessive speed
reducing the speed limits unlikely to
have any appreciable effect on the
number of crashes
i'm just going to go on now
it's reasonable to consider that driver
is responsible for crashes caused by
excessive speed are unlikely to take any
notice
of speed limits irrespective of what
they are
the key to reducing the number of
crashes due to excessive speed is to
identify and prosecute the offending
drivers
this can be carried out by various
measures
such as the use of road safety cameras
in high risk areas for example speed and
red light cameras
and i can tell my own experience as a
pedestrian around invercargill
especially around the inner city is that
people
running red lights are more dangerous
than
people speeding and also people with
looking at the jolly cell phone and not
looking at the road
so it should also be noted that road
safety enforcement is largely the
responsibility of the police
who it has noticed have struggled to
deliver results in use in this area new
zealand-wide and for further information
about the police's role in road safety
enforcement
i've in my submission i've put a
reference to
the ministry of transports 2021 report
review of road to zero road safety
investment which was uh a report looking
into
the
aspects of that campaign and also the
police's role in enforcement
so
in other words the key to identifying
and prosecuting drivers who travel at
excessive speeds is largely the
responsibility of the police and council
should engage with the police to come up
with an effective enforcement strategy
um
it would be more productive to focus
uh on the causes of the 88 of crashes
not caused by excessive speed because
the scope for reducing the number of
crashes is much greater
and the review of road to zero road
safety investment report i've mentioned
above
focuses on improving the safety of roads
by
what they call evidence-based tools to
identify the best solutions in high risk
areas
so these measures include new
roundabouts
medium barriers side barriers
widen center lines and so forth
and there may well be
times when a reduced speed limit is
appropriate in a certain area but
my submission is against the
district-wide reduction
and it's considered that council could
achieve better results by adopting this
broad-based approach because has the
potential to really make a difference
we live in a country where politicians
seem to think that change can be
affected simply by enacting legislation
unfortunately in reality it doesn't
happen that way for example
amendments to the firearms legislation
over the past few years were intended to
restrict and remove guns from the hands
of criminals
however as you will have noticed in the
media
the incidence of crimes involving
firearms has significantly increased
rather than
reduced
this is because criminals who use
firearms have no regard to the law and
i draw an analogy with the firearms
legislation
and the proposal to introduce a 40k
speed limit it might sound good and look
good on paper
but the question is will it make a
difference
in reality those who travel at excessive
speeds won't take any notice
of reduced speed limits and nothing will
change
the real question is
does council really want to make a
difference by identifying the best
solutions
to reduce the number of crashes
or merely give the impression of doing
so
and
in summary i would like to say
the biggest impact on road safety will
be achieved by focusing on the causes
of the 88 percent of serious crashes
that aren't caused by excessive speed
the key to ident is to identify and
prosecute
the offending drivers and the police
need to be part of the solution
council can carry out enforcement by
using road safety cameras in high risk
areas
and
finally
my view is the introduction of a 40k
speed limit will have little
or if any impact on the number of
serious crashes
those are my submissions uh mr chairman
and i'm quite happy to answer any
questions okay thank you jeffrey we have
a couple of minutes uh left now for
questions
councillor clark you've been very quiet
today
not as always uh jeffrey thanks for your
submission just a couple of things
just tease out a little bit more with
you
um
you'll have noticed recently you know to
tara that we dropped the speed limit
from 100 down to
um
70
put a lot of signs up but we still end
up with eight and a half thousand
infringement notices so
he's suggesting that regardless of
signage and regardless of changing speed
limits we still get people who want to
go a little bit faster
yes mr chairman i i
i think there's
probably a few other issues because i
know that piece of road and it was
previously 100k and then it's been
brought down to 70k although i do notice
that there are a numerous 70k signs so
that's
that's hard to uh explain why people
are traveling so quickly perhaps 80k
would be a better speed limit for that
area
but i mean
what what you're doing is identifying
and
penalizing the speeding drivers which is
the right way to go
so if they don't learn after getting a a
few infringement notices
what else can you do
and the other thing i'd like to say is
just your idea how you get to the 88
that you refer to out of the nzta report
the 88
in the council's review document that
said
12
of crashes were due to other factors
factors other than speed
yep so so what would your position be on
how we deal with the people running red
lights or the people focused on cell
phones while they're driving
well there are
red light cameras in some cities i think
christchurch has
recently put them in and and
i know having worked in local government
for many years i know that you can
you will have colleagues in christchurch
who you'll be able to
touch base with and see how effective
they are
speed cameras can be used in high risk
areas
and
i know there is technology
that australia uses to
pick up people using cell phones and
vehicles but i don't think we've got
that far in new zealand
thank you for that
okay right and we've come to the end up
councillor skill thank you through
youtube thank you jeffrey for your
submission you focused a lot today on
the 88
yes i'm interested in the 12 obviously
which does
from fact and data and the india police
does increase the fatality with speed it
does yes no question about that so i'm
more concerned in the sense of
what your response is
what what's the positiveness if we do
nothing
because we've got 12 percent which we
know in fact
of increased fatality yes speed so what
what's the positive that you can give us
question if we do nothing
i think i i don't say
do i say
be selective where you impose
a lower speed limit
rather than a district-wide speed limit
and
i think using those tools if you
identify an area where you think a lower
speed limit will
have an advantage have some benefit
by all means and i think the rest of the
population will
will buy into that but i think a
district wide speed limit of
an an urban area of 40k i i think you're
just going to have
a widespread disregard for it
so just so i'm clear you're
acknowledging that we do need to do
something yeah yes and and and there are
a wide range of uh options available
but
my view is just imposing a district-wide
urban 40k speed limit is unnecessary
unproductive and
you you you just won't people just won't
stick to it so at the end of the day
nothing will be achieved
thank you okay we're time is up
unfortunately council lewis um thank you
jeffrey
for your submission you've raised some
good points
thank you for the opportunity to make
this my submissions
right next we have
christine and is it annika
and you may take your mask off to speak
as well
that's if you want to
be easier
excuse me while i read off my phone
mourinho
honorable mayor and councillors thank
you for the opportunity to speak to you
today
my name is anka hebgood my husband and i
have four children and our family lives
on brown road which is a wee gravel road
off mill road north in the morris bush
area
i wrote two submissions
so the first one was specific to the
speed limit on our road brown road for
which i sought and obtained majority
support from my neighbours
my second submission was the views of my
husband and i only and nothing to to do
with our neighbours
so address the first submission first
regarding the proposed speed limit of 60
kilometres per hour for brown road
in our view while this is a great
improvement on the current 100
kilometers per hour limit our submission
is that it should be further reduced to
40 kilometers per hour
brown road is only just 500 metres long
it is gravel steep cambered straight and
it is a no exit road
our oldest child is 11 we also have an
eight-year-old six-year-old and a
three-year-old there are other young
families living on our road as well and
um
their children have similar ages
and when people drive fast down our road
our biggest concern is for the safety of
our children
and given our roads only 500 metres
there's really no point in driving fast
well i think in general people are
sensible when driving down our road and
almost 10 years we have lived on brown
road we have regularly advocated for
people to slow down whenever the
opportunity arose
whether this was the teenager living
down the end whose friends didn't
realize how unnecessary their speed was
or the rubbish track that seems to
always be in a hurry
or the occasional tanker or stock track
that is driving too fast for the
conditions
well i think in general
um
i'm sorry there was one rubbish truck
company that i rang a few times to
respectfully ask them to slow down they
were always great over the phone but
unfortunately i didn't see any change
happening in practice
one day i happened to be out in my
driveway as the truck sped past and so i
waited for the truck to speed back past
and was out there to wave them down
it they the truck driver did see me wave
out but it took them a long time to
break to a stop and i had to run to
catch up with them
to be fair the rubbish truck driver was
very receptive to my concerns when i
explained that we have a young family
and we're concerned with the potential
impact of their speed
the rubbish truck company has been a lot
more careful driving down our roads
since that time which we very much
appreciate
generally tanker drivers are pretty
careful driving but i've had to ring the
tanker company too on occasion
and i guess the difficult part about
ringing up people is that brown road has
been 100 kilometer
speed zone
and so no one has actually been breaking
in the limit as such
uh instead i've just got to rely on
people's goodwill and understanding
asking them to be more careful for the
sake of our children
i guess my point in telling you all this
is that i don't think i should have to
be contacting and negotiating with
people to request them to drive at a
safe speed what would be great is
instead to have a sensible lower speed
limit with signage at the start of our
road
each time i turned down into brown road
i found that 40 kilometers an hour is
pretty much a comfortable speed to drive
and one that is much more sensible in
terms of the safety of our children
therefore our submission is that the new
speed limit for brown road should be 40
kilometers per hour
this is the speed limit that i've
discussed with most of our neighbours
and the majority of our neighbours sign
their support
this was attached to my submission along
with our own personal with our neighbors
own personal comments supporting 40
kilometers per hour is the new speed
limit
so yeah take a time to read the
neighbor's comments too if you can
so that was my first submission and my
second submission now is a bit more
broader um while my husband and i
generally support the reduction of speed
limits throughout the invercargill
district we think this is an important
opportunity for invercargill city
council to consider these changes in the
context of creating a pedestrian cyclist
friendly in roading network
one of the issues that reducing speed
limits presents will be the compliance
of drivers to the lower limits however
in our view that is mainly because of
roads our roads so wide and clearly look
like roads that are made for vehicles
only
drivers assume that they command the
road while pedestrians and cyclins
cyclists only venture out with
significant risk
the roads in the morris bush area for
example are okay for adults to cycle on
bearing risk however they are by no
means safe at all for children or even
young teenagers to walk along or cycle
along
these roads need to be redesigned so
they start to look like shared
environments this will significantly
help drivers adjust to lower limits and
sharing the road space it will also
provide better opportunities for
pedestrians and cyclists to increase the
use of these roads
so i've been practicing driving at the
proposed speed limits
for example 80 kilometers of an hour
down mill road north and i think it will
take a little bit of time to adjust to
traveling extensively at this speed
within that in the cargo district
but i know from when i have driven
vehicles overseas in europe that good
road design lends itself to creating
roading networks that are suitable for
speed
and in contrast when i drove on much
smaller roading networks within with
stricter speed limits overseas once
again good road design meant that i
wouldn't even consider driving any
faster
it is important for the roading
environment to lend itself to being a
shared space with pedestrian cyclists
and other road users
and by way of road design it is possible
to create appropriate visual and
physical physical cues which would go a
long way to reducing road speeds to
sensible speeds and compliance with a
certain speed limit would hardly be an
issue
this is where we think that invercargill
city council needs to look at the bigger
picture when it comes to its roading
network
it needs to be working to a vision of
creating a safer roading network for all
users all users not just motorised
vehicles
reducing road speed is only one aspect
of this road design and network design
are also crucial
we know that this will take time to
implement
but there needs to be a solid plan to
work towards
the aim of course should be to optimize
spending in terms of linking up existing
tracks parks and green spaces together
where possible but then in other areas
ensuring good road design will help
motorists drive according to shared
roading
according to driving in a shared roading
environment
i did make a couple of additional points
in my written submission but i want to
allow time for questions as well
um
so yeah thanks for your time listening
today
and i'm happy to answer any questions
anybody has about those two main points
that i've made okay right we've got
about three minutes for questions so
councillor clark
councillor abbott and then council
ludlow
council clerk sorry chair that was up
from the previous speaker radio no
that's fine uh councillor abbott
oh yes thank you for that um dust can be
hazardous to driving too would the 40
kilometer an hour alleviate that yeah of
course um slower you go the less dust
there is on brown road though that's not
my primary concern i know my neighbours
did mention that it's a concern to them
generally those neighbours that signed
in support of my submission were all
the kind of people that drive slowly
anyway and so that's why it wasn't an
issue for them um and part of that
reason for them is dust as well as
um
our young children on on our road
yeah it can be hazardous
okay councillor ludlow
thanks cheer uncle how many uh families
are there in the brown road area
uh so there's eight uh main
residents so to speak um so one two
three four of those residents have um
children or grandchildren
um
living or visiting regularly thank you
for the questions
thank you very much then
and
okay right
thank you very much for your time thank
you
right we're here
uh i must cheer yes
my hand keeps disappearing i don't know
why so that's why i have to wave to you
sorry
if you can yeah that's that's fine yep
right next we have noel peterson are you
with us now
uh
everyone um yes thank you for the
opportunity to speak uh tennoco to qatar
um i i'd
like to say that i
fully support the council intention to
lower the rate speeds
i think it's a good move forward to
reduce accidents
and personal harm and deaths
and that said lowering the speeds on
paper doesn't reduce the speeds
and i've sent through a um
a um a word document with some notes i
hopefully you you will um receive that
and i've actually put it in the chat
if you haven't received it right
now we've all got that thanks now thank
you that's good good to go then
um
i'd i'd like the council to consider
um
putting in place further speed reduction
options in the future as the opportunity
arises as well
and uh that's
partly what my
notes are about
unfortunately i i know there's a lot of
people driving around the city and the
expensive speak
throughout the city
on a regular basis um during the day and
particularly at night
and
i
i actually walk around the city
a lot
both day and night
and
i can hear them coming and sometimes you
can hear them coming from
a suburb
on the other side of town
and
they're um out of control
and and there's nobody there to stop
them
so
and and
you know um sometimes we call them boy
races but um my observation is that it's
not just boys
a lot of them are adults and they
shouldn't know better um but they just
act in the clients of
the law i guess
um
regularly here and there was a
one in the newspaper yesterday over an
accident with a cab on a bike
or a person on a bike i should say
and uh
that's the
harm
and uh and speed seems to be a a
recurring factor in that in that
situation
i um started off my notes by um pointing
out about saving fuel and i know that's
sort of a slightly little tangent to um
what we're used to talking about we're
always talking about
reducing physical harm and and
reducing the accidents but um
in this day and age and i think that
regency feel was also an important
factor and i
i noticed a small sustainable business
of
network and they made the statement and
they researched it well that
reducing speed by eight kilometers um
would save up to fifteen percent in
shield
and uh
you know
without being a rocket scientist
and a 16k reduction gives you a 30
percent reductable
um generation less with the government
organization
is also saying if i'm saying
uh talking about 10 to 20 savings
and without a
significant increase in
in the time that it takes you to travel
from one place to the other trip time
so
and like
they're saying heavy vehicles um
it's uh
20 percent borrowing by going at 90
kilometers now instead of 100
some of the statue
relates to nzta highways and whatnot but
um
i i think that um
we really need to start looking at uh
an education agency because i think the
solution to this problem you know i just
heard one of the other submitters say
well you know if they don't take any
notice what do you do
well i i can remember back when i was a
lad
and that the councils um and they were
the city councils or the county councils
they they actually had a
an education
department
that was focused on on road safety
and back in those days the cars were
always um you know pretty useless brakes
when they run lots of roads
and uh what not so
um but it seemed to work
and and over the years um that seems to
have disappeared and it became civil
defense um it's the same sort of
organization that um
and that
there was you know people forever
telling the young people about the
dangers of speed and reminding everybody
else about speeding
so i'm not quite sure how you would put
that together
perhaps it's a combined effort um
between the nzta
civil defense council and the police so
a combination with it
at the moment we just seem to have
um big
broad picture and messages from nzta
which nobody um
hears too often or takes too much enough
so
i i just think that that's that's
important
and and
targeted education programs within that
so
you know if we
let's let's
i mean talking to us talking about it i
think is really really great
if we can target the education
targeted about those guys that are
driving around at 70 to 100 kilometers
an hour plus around our cities and
during the day and at night
i see them and i hear them and they
have seen them here as well
and they're just um
flying to heaven
so and then
it's going to take an attitude change
we we um
we seem to have
sort of accepted that and that's the way
it is
and people just float around wally nelly
and do what they like
and we need to design um those um
education programs
and so we get the buy-in from the
community from the majority of the
community and in fact the majority of
the community
are good people and our good drivers
or cyclists or walkers and
so you know let's not hang it on
everybody
and we need in that um attitude change
to give them clear methods that speeding
is not
okay um we need to i i suggest improving
the signage um
we need more of those signs that blink
out that say slow down there's one when
i i live in blood when i come into blood
there's one that tells you you're going
too fast and then it tells you when
you're doing 50 days or not and that
works really really well
um
people actually do um use it so
more of those around
and not just outside schools
we need signs that um have flashing
lights
and i think that um
better street signs and
the reflective blue and white um street
signs um would work really well i can
remember those starting off and right
over
spreading through the bar painting and
like in the dark and trying to find a
street
makes it really good
um speed cameras yep i don't know
who should run them
um but
i think we need
way more cameras
and and run them in places where um
people uh are not going to expect to
find one
and uh that could be just i think they
should be discreet
and maybe it's in partnership with the
police i think that's probably the
answer
and and when with infringements i think
that
would
combine with the education um you know
infringements need to be discretionary
if you've gone five k's over the speed
member or whatnot well then hey do we
need to give you a ticket you know do we
need to give everybody a ticket and get
the backs up
um it's targeting those speedsters those
guys that are actually uh no
you've just about reached the 10 minutes
so
no that's fine is there anything you
want to sum up and briefly yep
yep better lighting better road
reflectors
and uh
you know work towards wakata he's asking
for
and you know they put in a video there
about you know the
journey to a road to zero
and then um
there's a whole lot by the iaea which
gives um suggestions about saving fuel
again
and because of the war um in the ukraine
and i i just wanted to point out also
that speed reduction
reduces climate change so there's an
article about the heat wave and together
no that's that's good thank you no i'll
leave it there um yep
any questions uh no unfortunately you've
consumed your 10 minutes time yep yes
there is no time for questions thank you
that's great i've got my message across
and i'm available
thank you thank you for your submission
mark simmons
welcome mark
if you'd like to take a seat
and
you may remove your mask if you if you
wish
and your glasses
thank you um all right can you just move
the mic yep just in front thanks
thank you mayor shadbolt and councillors
for this
opportunity
i'm a uh
a long time resident of invercargill
city
a pedestrian and an occasional cyclist
and a motorist
i've driven over one million
kilometres
predominantly in new zealand but also in
half a dozen foreign
countries
without an accident
that doesn't make me an expert or
necessarily a good driver but um
it does qualify me
i think to
contribute to to this debate
many in this audience will
remember that a previous prime minister
who was to attend a rugby match in
wellington was reportedly driven at
speeds of up to 180 kilometres an hour
over a distance of
um 195 kilometers an average speed of
147 kilometers an hour
thankfully
she didn't suffer any injury and went on
to an illustrious
career in at the un
my point here is that
speed per se
doesn't kill but
collisions most certainly do
and that applies to every transport mode
whether it be road rail
air or sea
so i think uh
a real focus should be
on the prevention of collisions
speed exacerbates
every collision as we as we well know
and that's probably the reason why we're
having this
discussion
now i think there should be more focus
on collision avoidance through
uh training
of road users and i include uh
pedestrians cyclists and motorists in
that group
and vehicle technology
and road engineering
the
effect of
blanket speed reduction such a such as i
see being proposed will be to further
dumb down and de-skill
the driving fraternity
and at the same time
act as a drag on productivity when we
should be doing exactly the opposite
extrapolate the trend will take us back
to
the the red flag act of 1865
where
there was a man with a flag in front of
every vehicle 50 metres out in front and
six kilometers an hour was the limit
it was 30 years or more before the limit
was increased
and
the red flag man was made redundant
i think that the good and safe driving
uh really requires a number of things
and one of them is the elimination of
impairment
and
alcohol of course as well
canvassed on this
in this area but
i refer specifically to the increasing
evidence of drug taking
resulting in
impairment of drivers
in addition
the application of common sense good
judgment
and plenty of practice
is
important in driving
then i mentioned in my submission the um
mixing of transport types
on a single carriageway
it's inherently dangerous
i specifically refer to cycling
a lot of our roads are not
designed for it
and
but
cyclists do use them
and we have this tension
happening i
vivid in my memory as a visit to um a
trade show in germany
and walking on the streets of cologne
and seeing a um a heavy truck
uh pinning a
uh cyclist
to to the ground
um
he was just pinned there
injured
unable to get out
people around trying to help
and i've never forgotten it but it just
illustrates that uh we're doing
dangerous things
that
in a business we would eliminate
these hazards
because that's our responsibility as
persons conducting a business
undertaking but it seems like on the
roads
we will mix these things up
and
we take the consequences
so
i think that
in invercargill city we're not uh
amsterdam
which would be you know probably one of
the poster cities for cycling
the the population density is probably
30 40 50 times what houses and we need
to get things in perspective
we do have very good
cycling
uh possibilities
throughout the city and the green spaces
and with the um
the track out to bluff and
that these can be developed in time
motorists and transport operators you
know facing this issue every day
and i believe we're getting a bit wary
of
the um
you know being a cash cow
for governments and perpetuity to milk
for infrastructure while at the same
time being the whipping boy for
every
problem
in the transport network
then moving to
the school
scenario i
submitted that the present limits were
sufficient adequate
but noted that
there is
a penis scope for improvement
with direct safety benefits
typically students arrive
in a plethora of vehicles that
discourage large numbers on the street
or the the streets in the immediate
vicinity of schools
there's scant management organization in
control
and it's hazardous and disruptive for
residents and other road users
now i've personally observed schools in
foreign countries where delivery and
pickup takes place
in a managed environment off the street
by the on-the-school
property
in one of those cases that i'm familiar
with
that was in direct response to a
fatal accident involving a student
i'm currently managing a new school
build project in southland where we're
implementing this same solution
i would expect pretty stiff resistance
from government ministries and schools
on grounds of
liability and cost and so forth but if
we're as serious as we claim to be
about safety then i think it is
something that should be
implemented
in conclusion i'm
i'm generally against the wholesale
lowering of speed limits across the city
and i am for
targeted solutions based on training
uh technology and engineering
happy to take questions okay just
checking the time we've got a couple of
minutes for questions and counselor
ludlow then
clark
thank you with the school drop-off zones
um
do you think in the design that you're
involved with
do you think they can be self-managed or
that they need to be supervised
well i think if they're properly
designed the degree of supervision uh
would be less
but
yeah it's all a matter of setting up a
system that will will run and
and and enforcing it
thank you
thank you councillor council
clark
yeah thank you mark um
just wanted to tease out a little bit
about the drive through capacity you
you're referred to
have you seen the uh drive-through
capacity or facility at otaru school
no i haven't
yeah so suggest to you that you do have
a look at that
what we've learned from that is that
drop-offs are great when they go through
a drop-off system parents just kiss and
drop and it's great
but as councillor ludlow alluded to it's
the pickups that the problem because
people come in they get into that zone
to pick up the child but the child's not
ready
so you get massive congestion inside the
zone so we're just going to keep this
sorry about this counselor clark it's
very important but we'll just keep to
questions rather than solutions at this
stage
right but this is a very important topic
so yeah
okay we're 10 minutes is up now thank
you mark
okay
michelle francis
welcome rachelle
if you take a seat
and you may take your mask off
to speak
uh
[Music]
and i'm here to um
to applaud your um
openness to
reducing speed limits
across the board um for the well-being
um
of our community
so um i
apologize that i haven't had a chance to
write something down to speak to you
today so please if you could um let me
know when i get to five minutes so that
i can stop and have time for questions
okay i'll do that thank you
um
so i've been
harvesting
a rainbow chard from one of the
council's um
park beds and otakura park and putting
it out for the public to collect the
neighbours
day altered which we're celebrating this
week so
um
all right so
i think that we need these um
decreases and speed limits to be
implemented um because really
this um this council is here to look
after our people
it's not about looking after the cars
it's about looking after the people
and
i
want to share with you a story prior to
lockdown which was
when i was contacted through a facebook
page to go and collect some heritage
roses
from
the garden of an elderly lady in south
invercargill
she was removing all of her roses from
her garden because
she had been hit
by a car
traveling probably at the speed limit i
would say
along alice road
in south city shops she was critically
injured
she spent many months
recovering from this accident and now
uses a walker which means that she is
unable to
tend to her garden as she once
the impact of that lady
lady's life from being hit by a car has
been severe
and this is exactly the kind of thing
that can be avoided through lowering the
speed limits
in our shopping areas
and actually across
all of our urban streets
another story i want to share with you
is
during lockdown i think two years ago
tomorrow
we all went into our first level four
lockdown
and i remember walking and cycling the
streets of invercargill to get our daily
exercise together with our family
and seeing all of the other families and
households that were out
enjoying the traffic free streets
safely
peacefully
i'm sure you have fond memories of that
as well i remember at the time thinking
i never want this part of lockdown to
end
and actually we can learn both from the
successes of the past and the mistakes
from the past
in terms of building a brighter future
our streets don't need to be dominated
by cars we can design them for the
benefit of our families
our children our elderly our people with
disabilities
so uh
another story you would have seen in the
news yesterday
flash floods and auckland
um rain at 17 millimeters per hour
exceeding the definition of torrential
rain by almost 75
and
this as evidence of
accelerating storm events due to climate
change
this council does not have a climate
change policy which i have to say is
just have to look we are talking about
speed review okay in the submissions
so i understand that this speed review
is an example of a way that we can lower
our climate emissions
through communicating to our community
that there are alternative options to
fossil fuel transport
and that and encouraging them by
creating
walkways and cycleways that are pleasant
to use
i
know that many of you will have
experienced various um traffic free
uh shopping areas um
and your travels throughout aotearoa and
five minutes just thank you
and i'm sure you'll agree that there are
a lot of um
cultural and
economic benefits to the businesses
and those
car free
shopping districts and it's very
pleasant to use them so
yeah
there's more in my written submission
but i'll stop now and get now well that
just leaves you some question time
okay so we've got about four and a half
minutes question time um
counselor
thanks rachelle i just need to
understand a little more about the
accident on alice road straight road
how on earth did the woman get hit
she was crossing on the pedestrian
crossing right okay and the car was
traveling too fast to
stop in time and it plowed into her
thank you sorry i thought she must have
been gardening on the side of the road i
think oh no no she was shopping yeah her
garden is in a different location
thanks
my misunderstanding
thanks so much
for the questions
um you do have a couple more minutes so
if you do like if you'd like
any
anything else you'd like to raise
yeah i guess lastly um
i just want to share the fact that um
my all of my children my my biological
children and my bonus child through
marriage
cycle
to school every day
it causes me significant stress and
anxiety to know that they are sharing
the road with vehicles that are
traveling
um
you know at 50 plus kilometers an hour
on the roads beside them and
often don't
have a lot of consideration for them
i
believe that reducing the speed limits
both around the schools and in our urban
streets generally will create a much
safer environment for my children
and will
reduce
my anxiety around them cycling daily
to school and chicago an activity which
they really enjoy
apart from when it's hailing
and
and
which they get significant health
benefits from in terms of
being physically fit and healthy but
also
their mental health in terms of having
um
just a time where they are outdoors
where they're not looking at screens
where they're just able to i guess be
involved in a mindful activity of
cycling to and from school
and by
lowering speed limits across the city i
believe that we'll encourage
many more people in our community to
take up the benefits of walking and
cycling to where they need to go
and
and overall we'll have
a healthier and happier community so i
just want to say
thank you so much for
listening to me
um
we've got one more minute left and i'm
going to get a question from councillors
open for you thank you mr chair rochelle
you said it was preferable to have
one-way streets in the city centre
would you like to see more one-way
streets or are you just meaning keep the
ones already there
i think that one-way streets are
a very effective tool in terms of
improving safety
um making streets more cycle and
pedestrian friendly so
in general i think that
one-way streets more one-way street
one-way streets are good and more
one-way streets now city center would be
a good thing
thank you okay thank you very much
rachelle thank you so much for your time
okay
right
um we have one more submitter for this
first session this morning and that is
matt furnis
who arrived here nice and early
didn't want to get caught in a traffic
jam
or speed
i came at the speed limit too
right
um
hello everyone
in my submission today i want to talk
about risk
the standard textbook definition is the
effect of uncertainty on objectives
i don't expect to remember that
what this translates to in the
vernacular is the possibility of the
brown stuff
hitting the rotating air mover
i want to talk about risk because risk
is fundamental to this particular topic
and i want to bring a particular
perspective to this discussion
the perspective of a professional
engineer with a few kilometers on the
odometer
professional engineers among other
activities identify hazards and quantify
risks
and set about finding and implementing
solutions to hazards based on risk
levels that have been determined to be
acceptable
the best way to understand this is to
think about an example and i'm thinking
about the flood protection scheme so
civil engineers in this town knew that
if it rained here quite heavily or in
the district
there was a chance that part of the city
would flood so they must have come to a
meeting like this
and said we need to do something about
this let's design a flood protection
scheme
so the vexatious question is
what level of flooding are you prepared
to accept
is it a full day of rain is it five days
of rain a week a month of rain what do
you want to do
so the engineers go back to the
statistics they come back to you guys
and say
do you want to design for a one and five
year flood a one in ten one in fifty one
and a hundred you tell me i'll do the
design
so you set
the risk level
what are the chances of the brown stuff
contacting the rotating air mover that's
how it works
so
with this understanding let's talk about
speed management
human beings are good at a lot of things
but we have a lousy design speed we can
do five kilometers per hour that's a
walking speed
if you adhere to this design speed
you are at a very low risk of suffering
any damage
so the brown stuff won't contact the
rotating air mover
but it will take you 40 hours
of this effort to get to dunedin that is
a full working week
a full working week of time to get to
dunedin
so
many years ago a long time ago people
decided they want to travel faster than
their design speed
and so horses were pre-scanned into
service for several centuries with
people on their backs and guess what
happened people got injured and people
got killed because they were exceeding
their design speed
the two go hand in hand
then someone invented the wheel and the
internal combustion engine
and the roading network and it's now
possible to travel at 20 times
your design speed on our roading systems
and with it
with that 20 times
comes an increase in the chance of the
brown stuff contacting the rotating air
mover
and guess what
20 times it's not two times it's 20
times that's a lot
and with it comes an increase in risk
now let's look at some facts
this is the lies damn rise and
statistics part of the whole thing
deaths peaked in 87 at about 800 a year
they gradually decreased with the
introduction of the japanese imports my
opinion and improved car design to
around three to four hundred deaths in
2003 where it essentially remains today
how do we compare to the rest of the
world the stats are as follows holland
and germany 3.8 deaths per 100 000
people
australia 4.5 new zealand 7.8 deaths per
100 000
usa 12.4
vietnam 24.5 world average
18.2 deaths per hundred thousand
so we are tracking reasonably well in a
world perspective
the vic's question for the public is how
many deaths are acceptable
if your answer is zero
then you
and the people from the transport agency
have got to go to the naughty corner
because you didn't listen to what i just
said
increased risk
now let's talk about deaths
this is the nasty bit
unfortunately death is a fact of life
every day in new zealand 90 people die
of something 90 people
here's a snapshot 26 people die of
cancer
14 die of heart disease seven of stroke
two of diabetes two people every day
take their lives
and one person dies on the roading
network
now all of those except the writing
network bring zero zero zero benefit to
this country zero
the vic's question is is one death on
the road per day given the immense
personal
and almost immeasurable commercial
benefit the writing system brings to the
people of new zealand is it acceptable
and secondly if saving lives is your
focus
are there other areas that could benefit
from some spending rather than chasing
this pipe dream of zero road deaths now
if you ask me my answer is yes
we are comfortably situated between
australia and america
in the death statistics
and we're comfortable below the world
average of 18.2 deaths per 100 000
is it a competition i wasn't aware it
was a competition
this sounds pretty good to me
but if i wasn't directed or guided by
the new zealand transport agency and you
may well guess i'm not
then if you ask me as a professional
engineer can you reduce the road toll
right now let's say yes you can
the la the answer lies in the domain of
the professional engineers again
for a long time
we improved all the safety aspects of
the automobiles
these improvements reflected in the
stats since 87 when the japanese imports
improved the vehicle fleet by
introducing crumple zones airbags
anti-lock braking traction control and a
host of other improvements made possible
by the development of computer-based
tools we didn't have them until the 80s
then we could design the crumple zones
and the microprocessors which became
reliable and cheap and very effective so
we could implement all these safety
features they made a vast difference to
the safety of our roading network
those
advantages have all been grabbed they're
still improving but at a diminishing
rate the answer now lies in the design
of the highways if for example
highway one was redesigned into four
lanes two one way to the other with a
big separation barrier the road toll
would decrease significantly
this is an obvious fix but it would be
too expensive to implement and is likely
parked on some shelf at the new zealand
transport agency because of the
difficulty and cost of this particular
solution instead the transport agency
have embarked on a vision that is
fundamentally and fatally flawed
it flies in the face of the very reason
the roading system was created in the
first place the need for humans to
exceed their design speed
i don't buy into their vision
which is why i've taken the time to
present my perspective to you today
now i'm going to leave you with the
ubiquitous executive summary number one
exceeding your five kilometer per hour
design speed could get you killed
number two the chances of it happening
in the current roading network in new
zealand are very small and within
reasonable limits from a global
perspective
number three
there are many other areas that need
attention if saving lives is a priority
in this country
and finally
the design of the routing system should
be the first priority if minimizing road
deaths is the focus of the new zealand
transport agency
thank you very much for your time
there's well said matt um i'm going to
open up questions now i'm going to go
council lewis thank you matt thank you
for the presentation i understand your
stats on on depth and things like that
and that's probably the major issue that
the nz transports looking at but do you
happen to have the stats at the hand
about the
the
coherent injuries which do
of no result in ongoing costs when i
when i looked at this i went to the
worst case
yeah
so you might
we haven't got the figures there anyway
so we can't take in the cost of the
injuries in a long time
if you take in the cost of reducing the
speed limits allow me to do the numbers
if i apply the algebra they will be in
the trillions
the trillions if i take my guys and i
have to go to ty and it takes me extra
time at their hourly rate and multiply
multiply multiply by that algebra
then decreasing the speed limits will
cost in the billions it might even i
don't know it could be billions probably
don't know what the number is but i'd
say to be massive in a year
a few kind
um was sorry council adelaide did you
have your hand up you did sorry and then
then counselor cop
thanks matt for the um for the
perspective
can i just clarify then do you think
that waka katahi have a flaw in their
current
methodology whereby when the
quality of the roading network drops
that they drop the speed limit rather
than fix
the road
um interesting question
i if if i
i'm so angry about what they've produced
zero road deaths by
whatever date that i'm almost
instructing the minister of finance not
to use any of my taxes to give them any
money
i i think that that transport agency
needs a big reshuffle
so i don't respect anything they produce
thank you let's go
leaving aside waka kotahi's ambitions
for zero deaths
which um
if you have lost somebody on a road you
probably
support and endorse because one death is
that relates to you is one there's too
many correct however that's not the
principal focus of what we're looking at
which is the overall quality of
experience for the members of the city
of invercargill as they traverse the
city of invercargill so
the overall the question i'm asking you
the question i'm asking you is do we
design
and manage the speed within the city
solely for the benefit of people who
want to travel faster or do we look at
all the people in the city of
invercargill and their various ways of
navigating the city of invercargill and
look at how we can balance those things
what do you think my answer's going to
be to that did you listen to what i said
my answer is
i think we're doing pretty well
so you have to balance we're balancing
everything as we are right now
so as a pedestrian
who lives somewhat proximate to
south city
and experiences on an almost daily basis
the traffic that does not slow down for
pedestrian crossings because they're
looking at whether they can beat the
traffic lights
what is your what do you think we
are asking
and how do you balance that
what sort of question that like these
are behavioral things aren't they
yeah i think this is after a solution so
yeah i'm gonna you don't have to answer
i i'm i'm bringing a perspective of risk
that we and uh
you know you have to if you make if you
make decisions
based on what your neighbor you know
your neighbor experience has lost and so
on and so forth i've said
there are 90 people die every day in
this country of something death is a
part of life
so good decision making has it has to
have a balanced perspective
not
the squeaky wheel or not the
tugging at the heart strings because of
emotion
okay i've got um sorry matt i've got his
worship would like to ask you a question
yes thank you
the um
i was in holland and uh
and i hired a bike
in amsterdam
and
a car came out of a side road this is a
question you wish oh yes it almost said
um
do you
the cyclists in the area just swarmed
over this car and banged the roof of the
car
and it was sort of direct action if you
like and we had an example of it and
brown throw it at these
submissions as well
i would say i lived in holland for five
years uh there are bike lanes in holland
there are bike lights there are red
lights green lights and you have your
own bike lane it doesn't it's not the
same as here our network is not set up
as well as
most of europe
that's why our road deaths are 7.8 to
100 000
not 3.8
that's holland
holland has got main highways four lanes
each direction and so on so forth but i
think
for where we are with our little
two-lane skinny country we're probably
doing pretty well okay i'm going to have
to call this to an end now
you've actually you came at the right
time because that brings us to 10 30
which is our break right okay so you
actually got about 14 which is 14. yeah
i'm no thank you list thank you for
the enlightenment okay now we have a
break thank you very much everybody
just before we start
the next session um i have uh
an apology for
uh council lush who has had to leave um
i'll move that we accept that apology
thank you put the motion orders in favor
all right
can i just add to that oh i have to
leave it 12.
we'll vote on that later yeah
yes you may cancel
thank you
right daniel
welcome to the meeting
hello hello how are yours
pretty good
we're good we're good so
hey um i just i made a submission
recently about the um speed zones um
tara um
yeah there was an opportunity there to
speak to councillors obviously and i
thought i might as well because i know
maybe no one else will so i thought i
would
um yeah so
long story short shoots very long i
guess um
i brought property in um odata maybe
five or six years ago and i've been
building my house out there for the past
10 months or so
we've been pretty well established out
there though over the last few years uh
so the property is on hardwick road
which runs off eckers road um eckers
road which runs off odata road
it's a gravel road and five years ago
when i brought up it was a solid gravel
road
but over the years you know rain wear
and tear a lot of a lot of heavy traffic
coming going there's um
you know i've just built a house
neighbors have built a house there's
another six houses being built on the
other side of the road um right now so
it's um it's taking a bit of a hiding
and um
and it's it's literally extremely
dangerous i mean you come off odata road
onto anchors slightly seal
and then you hit the gravel
not not everybody but you know there's a
few people out there that can
continuously run it at 100 kilometers an
hour
and it's like driving on corrugated iron
you know um
and obviously the maintenance on it too
like the guys um your contractors come
out and grade it every other week
um but what they're now rating there's
nothing left there they're literally
turning over dust every every time it's
graded they're just turning over dust
there's no solid gravel there
um so what i've done you know with the
submissions of the speed zoning um we've
sort of congregated with um
a dozen of the of the neighbours who are
affected by the gravel and the dust and
speed
uh we submitted uh letters um
you know letters submissions to have the
uh speed reduced obviously
but i mean ideally we'd love to have a
road seal but i know there's cost in
that so i feel if we bang the couple of
60 kilometers kilometer signs up at the
start of the road
probably save you guys a fortune and
maintenance and um
yeah it could could save some lives
really that's um
you know we've had a few hairy ones we
were pulled out of hardwood road onto
axis road and people are screaming up
there doing 100k and it's not a very
wide road but it's one of those roads
like a
proper gravel road where you end up with
a track in the middle of it and if
you're not on the track you're literally
on four-wheel drive track you know
um
yeah so like our biggest concern is the
dust
i've had a big hedge line um that run
down 150 meters of their property which
we've just dropped um just um because
it was kind of encroaching on the power
lines and creating some problems so
we've dropped these trees which is
definitely exposed us to the dust
and you see it you know once these trees
have been dropped i've i've got brand
new water tanks there that are literally
gone from black to
dusty grey fairly quickly i and i think
you know too nobby you're the postman
out there you know the road
um
it's not it's not the best one and hey
there's probably another 100 roads out
there that you know you're probably
going to have people like me bugging
yours but
um i thought you know like this even at
my neighbor um roger deacon he's written
a letter and he said like it's a major
health concern for for the
residents you know just the dust is so
dense and it sticks to our roofs and
then it runs into our water tanks and
we're drinking it you know
yeah
um yeah so
um yeah i don't know like i feel i i try
to do a fit for a city you know i
contribute i pay my rate so i'm in the
process of bringing 30 artists down the
end of this year to beautify our cbd the
outskirts of the the new builds and
stuff um
and i just for oh well you know i do a
lot i try to do a lot
of views could help our air neighborhood
out which we're all rate payers and it's
going to be another like i say six
houses going up there this over this
year
i'm obviously usually going to get a few
extra dollars for rates so
hey come seal our road please
okay um
yeah some not quite a speed review
subject but definitely the dust
caused by speed is something council
ludlow
thanks there's a question coming in just
a second but i should point out that
more houses don't mean more rates money
it just spreads the load for everybody
else
um
has the particularly dry summer made
that dust um
even worse
uh i it has yeah i mean obviously when
it's when it's dry it's dusty but when
there's no gravel left and you're just
turning up dust every week like it's not
ever going to get better you know and
that's the thing like it will rain and
then it corregates because there's no
content to it it's literally just dust
and dirt you know um
and i mean yeah it's dusty in winter and
summer but then in winter you've got
massive potholes and you know
small lakes on all throughout the whole
road so
thank you
yes ms cook
you've highlighted
um you've highlighted the um particular
issue with your
your particular road but in your
submission you have been supportive of
reducing speed within the cbd
so um
[Music]
would you like to enlighten why you
haven't spoken so intensively to that or
is it just because the dust is
particularly bad today
uh
the dust this is my priority right now
this week baby girl who come a few days
ago so i know she's going to be affected
by it it's not so much me i'm worried
about it's a baby you know um
and then the elderly out there too like
my neighbor she's an elderly woman that
walks every day with her dog and people
speed past her and kick dust up in her
face every day so
um yeah hey and and i i am all for uh
speed reduction in general you know
there's i feel like there's no rush
we're in such a small town it's not a
bustling city no matter the situation
it's only 15 minutes one side to the
other
like um definitely for speed reduction
on the cpd from you know
uh yeah i mean nobby um
addressed an issue yeah we're not going
to
take
death tolls or from speed down to zero
at all but hey if we can make you know
let's not you know leave things as they
are so we end up with a death toll if we
can avoid it for what putting up a
couple of 60k signs you know or 40k
signs in town or whatever
okay council clerk
yeah thank you daniel
and as you said i've done the run out
there a couple of questions really more
on focus on the safety issue as opposed
to the dust
yeah
you live on a road that's
uh and like a lot of rural roads that
are not arterial so they're not major
roads running through they're more what
you call back roads
yeah
do the potholes really impact on the
especially in winter they impact on the
um
on the safety of people coming through
um so it's gonna have to it's gonna have
to interrupt there we are talking about
speed
and um and if potholes slow people down
that could be a good thing but this is
about speed
okay yeah it could be spinning
that's where we're going like the
potholes are created from speed you know
you go from 100k on a sealed road and
hit gravel that's where the potholes are
as soon as you hit that gravel boom you
know there's 50 meters of potholes right
on on the transition there's no potholes
on the rest of the roads you know and
that's from speed
so that's the issue
okay so
just to clarify for the committee here
that reducing the speed on your road
would reduce dust and potholes
definitely right okay anything else any
other questions council claim
no
right 10 minutes is up now thank you
very much daniel for that submission no
thank you
appreciate what you guys are doing and
all the best
congratulations
oh and thank you
we haven't slept for a few days but um
yeah buckle up
[Laughter]
all right
talk soon thank you thank you
okay we go to our next submission and
that is
raymond
welcome
take a seat and you can take your mask
off
wonder if i stand
uh we just need you to be close to a
microphone that's all is there a hand
microphone
yeah okay
and if you bring that mic
just forward a wee bit
good morning ladies and gentlemen
my name is ray ruffle i live on our bay
road which is a gravel road off ty road
and speaking to you today i'd like to
draw your attention to the petition
attached to my submission which shows
that i have the support of all the
residents in the area
this narrow road sees a high volume of
heavy traffic as it serves two gravel
pits
the trucks using this road will when
loaded be carrying between 50 and 58
tonnes depending on trailer design
what's the class of this rope is the
road classed for these weights
this load coupled with the speeds they
are driven at grinds the gravel surface
to a fine dust which contains silica a
known health hazard
these are not the only heavy vehicles
using this road
as there is a dairy farm some four
kilometers further around the road this
means not only a daily milk tanker but
also delivery trucks and stock trucks
private cars belonging to the workers
also managed to achieve very high speeds
i estimate one in particular goes from
35 kilometers to 100 kilometers in the
space of 300 meters
with a growing population of close to 30
people in a zone of less than one
kilometer and many of those people being
parents and grandparents the possibility
of one of our children or grandchildren
not to mention the recreational visitors
we see using the bay itself being
involved in an accident or in
is
sorry i'll repeat repeat that
being involved in an accident in it is
increasing
in the last three years we have already
seen at least six car crashes resulting
in property damage when drivers have
lost control on the gravel fortunately
no children were involved
the lake pat harris who used to live at
number 37
petitioned the council to have
conditions imposed on sand and gravel
when they were first granted an
extraction permit
about 28 years ago
that truck speeds must not exped exceed
40 kilometers per hour that they were
only to cart between 7am and 6pm
this was
permitted
after all the residents
were consulted all this has gone by will
be in your archives
pat battled for close to two years to
get these conditions and now they have
been overlooked
this was a legal battle which she won we
would prefer not to go down that road
again but times have changed and the
traffic is now 10 times what it was then
we are now seeing trucks operating from
6 30 a.m to 9 00 pm
no consultation took place or similar
restrictions imposed in respect of
southern stone
segment
in respect of
southern stone and timber
this affects all of us residents
so what can be done
the most obvious is to impose a speed
limit what we're here for today
we suggest 40 kilometers per hour
similar to the amawi community
but also
why not seal the road section for the
first one kilometer
as this would have the greatest health
benefits
a high initial cost but the savings and
maintenance grading over time would to
some degree offset this or maybe
the richardson group
would be willing to backload dynite for
this section of road
in setting a reduced speed limit
enforcement becomes an issue
why not install speed runs similar to
those at the tisbury school
at the end of the seal at the t row road
junction and another one at the one
kilometer mark along with the speed
signs
also the installation of temporary speed
cameras when the changes are made will
enforce the new speed limits
if this saves just one life then it must
be worth the attention it deserves
thank you ladies and gentlemen
thank you ray
questions
yes miss cook
um
right i remember very well that
application for that gravel put and the
restrictions and the efforts that pat
went through are you actually saying
that those
um consent conditions are not being on
it
very much so
very much so
yeah that's interesting i don't know
where we put that but um because he's
because ray is quite right i do remember
it is it is noted
yeah thank you and can be raised later
yeah
yeah further questions for ray
i would like to thank a member there
mrs
cook is it yeah yeah um thank you for
that
endorsement on that comment
because it was passed to me from one of
the neighbors and we're all working from
memory so thank you
right um you've got a couple minutes
left if you want to say any more or
otherwise it's
thank you very much
thank you okay thanks right
we now have brought forward mary o'brien
[Laughter]
um thank you very much it's really good
to be here and it's great to be able to
um join wisely
my name's mary o'brien i'm the access
coordinator
for the southern region of ccs
disability action and i also coordinate
our national student accessibility audit
which is a combination of
best practice transport engineering and
um
disability and accessibility
we we strongly support reduced speed
limits absolutely and utterly and as you
would have seen
in our submission we also submit that 40
k's an hour is um too much for many
urban roads
i'll talk about that a bit more in a
minute
by reducing the speed limits the council
will be fitting with the
government national policy transport
statement which is now putting more of a
focus on
safety and accessibility and including
people and transport planning
new zealand's not alone and not
including treat people in transport
planning so that's good to see that
happening
also fits
with the road to zero which is um
the national
strategy around road safety so i'm
certain that council will be working to
um
to meet those
requirements
um creatures at 30k
are much more survivable by drivers and
pedestrians
than crashes at 40k
and particularly um you know if you've
got urban areas where you've got a lot
of pedestrians it's a high use area and
people want to cross
that's that makes it safer for them
and also drivers have more of a chance
to see people and take a phase of action
we know that new zealand's got a
terrible
road crash record
and we have a lot of information and
evidence about that however
evidence about pedestrian safety
is very very limited and this is due to
um the poor reporting systems that the
police have and the fact that a lot of
people just don't um report crashes um
whilst we are a disability organisation
we advocate for um
very strongly for improved access to the
community for everybody
and as i said before there's not a lot
of evidence about
safety for pedestrians and crashes and
injuries and in particularly vulnerable
pedestrians
however one of our
partners
with the street audit who's a transport
engineer dr bridget doran she has done a
lot of research around why people don't
make road trips particularly walking
trips using the roads
and this is actually she's a
leading international researcher on this
one of the key things is the fact that
influences everybody's trip is the
perception of safety if people don't
feel safe they won't go
if people don't have access to a car
because they don't own one or it's too
expensive remember here we're talking
about vulnerable people
ranging from the young to the old to
families without cars all of those
things they don't go and often they
can't afford the bus
so if they're living on a road or an
area where there's a 40k speed
kids can't go to the shop on their own
they can't cross the road to the
neighbours and those sorts of things
because it's just simply um
too fast
so the important thing to remember
that's come out of that trip that if
people don't feel safe particularly
disabled people they either don't make
the trip the walking trip or they make a
longer more arduous trip so they have to
walk or wheel or whatever in a different
following a different route
so the issue about that is it's energy
and time
so
if you're elderly or you've got a young
child to push in the post chair or
you've got a mobility issue or a health
condition
that energy is really important you have
to measure it out
and what that actually just
boils down to is actually community
severance people aren't included in the
community and we don't know because we
don't measure it
and that's one of
our issues
yeah so that's basically we really
really support the safe areas around
primary schools that's really really
important we all know that
um children can often be unpredictable
there's also evidence suggesting that
those areas should be extended you know
quite a lot of accidents and things are
within one or 1.5 k's from schools
so that's um
really really important to address
and i just heard the um reminder of
ray's um
submission before us i didn't hear it
all but we fully support what he said
about speed issues and about traffic
calm calming
actions like speed bumps and
those sorts of things sorry there's the
cat
um
yeah so we support that what you're
doing we think that you need to do it a
to make um south and safe for people we
support that you need to do it to fit
with government policy i don't think the
council wants to be a council that
doesn't comply with government policy we
also warn you very carefully to be weary
of
people who say
that you know
speeds are going to make their trip
times longer they don't they really
don't i mean i'm sure we've all
experienced that um you know if you're
up on the open road
you know perhaps you might be driving to
go or something and some person passes
you at speed on the double yellow line
you always catch up with them
don't you when you get to the next stop
or the next slow pace yeah
so in summary we support it we think
that all the urban speech should be 30
and
yeah
that'd be very good to see that you
could be a leader in that so thank you
very much for the opportunity to submit
okay thank you mary we have uh time for
about four minutes worth of questions
so council ludlow
thanks for your submission mary my
question is around your suggestion of a
blanket
reduction
to 30 kilometers per hour
can i ask you
in all honesty what sort of compliance
do you think the city is likely to get
if it did
that i think compliance is it it is
always a bit of an issue i mean it's an
issue with everything you know with
smoke free cappings and all those things
and it's probably not something that the
council is going to be able to be you
know all the police
policing but a lot of people will police
it themselves you know they'll talk to
their neighbours and most people
actually obey the road rules
um
i think yeah that's important
and in time people will learn about the
changes and comply with them i do think
you've got um
but the public education around this is
important
because you're possibly more likely to
hear from
more from drivers than pedestrians yeah
thank you
um for the questions
there are no more questions mary so
thank you very much
um thank you very much for the
opportunity
right
that moves us now to
debbie and stacy
would you like to
set up the table here
counselor scout makes good concierge
is
well kiara hi i'm dewey dixon principal
wins inaudible school and i'd like to
introduce staci stinning our chairperson
of the windsor north school pta and we'd
both like to thank you for
providing this time for us to be able to
speak to you
um this morning in regards regarding to
the submission around the speed review
around the windsor community in
particular wins north school
we just provided a really summary
overview sheet um of the key messages
that we wanted to advocate
as part of the speed review and one
clear thing that has come really
strongly with the consultation of our
pta and school community
and the members of the board of trustees
is that we strongly feel that there
should be a 30k speed zone around the
windsor north school
area
and this really is advocating the
support of safe walking zones for not
only our winsor north school students
but our school has a sort of a
conjunction where we see a number of
james hargis junior high school students
senior high school students centuries
south and boys high school all walking
to and from school in those high peak
traffic times
one of the things that we really were
strong about with the 30k
introduction or
and introduction of that speed limit was
the stop driver confusion around the
windsor area
um and particularly we noted that
the suggestion was that all of
windsor street was to be 30 k's and a
little some of the side streets with
king street burke street catherine
street and um some of town we're
suggesting some most of chelmsford
street from number um 30
to wilton street which is across our
school pathway
and then also into layout street of
queens drive up to terrace street
because again that's where a number of
students
including our students are walking
um
we
also support this because there are a
number of near-misses every single day
even this morning
we are our students particularly
crossing from over windsor street into
the chelmsford street where we have
over 50 plus children
walking
every morning and after school with
their families and pushes and bikes and
scooters
and it is a really problematic area
because it's a very wide street windsor
street
um it has angled parking
so we've got cars backing out
um we've got cycle ways so there's sort
of like a four-way lane traffic and then
you've got little five-year-olds
scooting across and just playing
daredevil with the traffic as well as
intermingling with the boys high girls
high and and james hargis
bikes as well so it's a real problem
area i think it's really difficult also
for um
the cars because they can't see there's
some real blind spots with parking
along the
windsor street area
so that's one of our key things that we
we would just really like the council to
go ahead with that 30 case but keep it
30k
all day every day around that particular
area
i agree
[Laughter]
um yeah so in that diagram we just sort
of highlighted the orange which was
indicated in this review but just put
some suggestions particularly around
that layered street which we felt was
missed with james hargis jr
um
and then that helps the traffic going
into windsor straight
they can just understand that that's all
a 30k
area with with additional signage
um we didn't we felt that from number 30
so we tested it with our cars a little
bit just what would it be like going
from number 30 on chelmsford street um
along that 30k and up to wilton it was
much more doable
um and in onto windsor it just all felt
connective
um when we came and stacy and myself met
at the library with the team
and we also advocated some other areas
that part of this review is and we know
and understand it's not to do with speed
but it does connect with speed
um and particularly around safe walking
is that we have noticed three really
unsafe areas around our school
and that is windsor street with the um
angle parking
and the wide streets with the booth of
cycleways as well we want to keep those
cycle ways but we would actually like to
see the angle parking go
um we would also like the roundabout at
herbert street
um it isn't a very safe crossing area
for the students and for elderly and for
people because it is the crossing that
is there is very close i think we need
to keep this down too yeah sorry oh
sorry yeah we need to keep the speed
yeah but with the but what links with
the speed at the moment with the herbert
street roundabout is the anchoring of
breaks every single day onto that
crossing it has it's been raised earlier
this morning by some matter about people
approaching
roundabouts so i think that could come
up
come up in discussions
and
just um with the speed around that
wilton chelmsford corner as well because
there is a number of cars that just zoom
around there so that's why we'd advocate
for 30ks as well
okay look we've got uh submission yep
we've got time uh we've got about four
minutes for questions council lewis
thank you councillor clark
thank you mrs dixon for the very
succinct and this has been very useful
to highlight those speed areas that
may well be changed uh when there are
school buses outside in chelmsford
street sometimes there are double parked
or out from the little parking bay does
that become a problem with cars going
past at speeds greater than the 20k
permitted absolutely and we even have um
after-school care
um
vans and things and then it becomes
quite congested with the parking and the
speed thanks very much thanks mr nixon
okay um justin i've got councillor clark
then
councillor arnold
thanks team um just just
your views on something you said um you
suggested that the limit should be 30
case per hour
suggesting that there is
all day and every day or was it just in
the
start and finish times at school so
that's one issue
and the other issue is
um
would it be your suggestion that it
involves the weekends as well and i'd
just like to know what school activities
that might impact on
that's been the greatest debate about
the timing of the speed um in our
consultation to date as a school
community
and the board in the end just strongly
believe that it just needed to be 30ks
every single day because it again stops
that confusion
and then it also trains the traffic that
this is just always a 30k
area
they the school is used as a community
resource
every single day after school as well
and the weekends so again
to have that 30ks monday to sunday just
makes it easier easier to train the
community that this is a 30k zone
okay thank you councillor clark and we
have councillor arnold just a couple of
quick questions um the engel parks you
refer to they're actually um are they
actual school car parks though
no they're community this thing so just
general people park there yes
they must go to work or something do
that yes
the other thing if you notice that and
um i know you
you know you've carried on down wind
street if you notice that the traffic
there goes slow anyway with the because
you've got those speed humps at every
intersection
you know that are like a jada bar i
guess
the traffic is going slow unfortunately
that the speed humps are used as
pedestrian crossings and particularly
for children we've noticed
um that they just play chicken with them
because they don't know if they are a
crossing
or are they a speed hump so there's lots
of confusion in the windsor community
around the speed is fine because it is
slow but it's actually where the
crossing points are
right
that becomes quite problematic counselor
sofa
thanks mr chair debbie just wanted to
refer to to your written submission
and i understand everything that i'm not
going to ask anything about what you've
said because i think it's very clear on
your verbal one but in your written
submission you've said in reference to
reducing speeds on rural roads
that no speed should be set at 100
kilometers an hour for most rural roads
can you just expand on that because it's
a wee bit surprising in the lighting oh
no i think i must have taxed the wrong
one we did want to advocate the lower
speeds so yeah right thank you for
clarifying that
okay any further questions uh councillor
scott thanks debbie for the presentation
i just wonder if you can help me clarify
for me um
what would the positives be if we do
nothing
what with the positives if we're
currently the status play
i think that and the
growing speeds that we're seeing even in
the small street that we have i think
we're at risk of having more injury and
not near misses actually accidents and
deaths
there's no positives no
okay thank you we have come now to the
10 minute point so thank you
thank you for your time thank you
thank you stacy
we have another zoom
submitter
um
we have sharon help
um
i've never done anything like this so
it's but nerve-wracking um i just um
first of all like to mention i i just
heard from the last counsellor that
one of the counselors that um
knows that
he had said i'm not sure which one said
will be changed
and i just sort of felt like it was a
thing to say we're already made up in
minds and i kind of feel like that's not
a good start
no we haven't uh we haven't had
anyone on this council i've been
chairing the meeting
uh say things will be
changed we've said things are noted
uh that means that
things that people have said have been
noted
that are outside the speed review thing
but we have no one has uh crossed the
line of stating anything yet so
i'm sorry
the words i actually heard so i wrote
them down so but anyway moving on um i
i have said no
um
to most of it
um
i can't think of anything in my
submission that i haven't
um why uh
i think the danger that i have with all
of these decisions to try and lower
everything is that
um
where are you gonna stop
uh if you're
my understanding is that the school
zones are already zoned to
um a 40
kilometer kilometer
speed
limit
i don't understand why it needs to go
down to 30
it doesn't make any sense you're only
going to be bottle necking places like
james hargis
layard street
in areas like that and i think in the
cbd the same goes you're just doing a
bottleneck situation where you're
slowing all the traffic
um an ability to to be productive in the
areas
i think there's better things that can
be done um and i looked at um the
macarena morris bush and talisbury zones
wanting to um drop that to 40 k's
uh i think that
um
from what i've known in those areas that
i've passed through on
countless times for jobs and things like
that that is not affected
um i would say but haven't said that
tisbury i would be
i think is a concern and i would be more
looking at um
putting in a roundabout at that area
because you've got a lot of traffic that
crosses over that area
um from the main highway piece and i i
think that would be a better thing than
trying to lower it to 40.
um
what else have i said um
i
yeah um
like of south south i live in south city
and
um to slow an area like that down to 40
k's isn't going to improve any of the
traffic situation you've got there now
it's going to be harder for people to
get out of
um the new wheel parking which it
already is
um
and
it's not go there's pedestrian crossings
there that are utilized fine
um it's not gonna it's it's just gonna
slow the traffic down in such a bad way
that there's going to be more disruption
and i'm i'm confused about the
the injuries and things like that from
what what what
what has brought this about and the fact
that when i've looked at data for um
injuries and that's a thing there is
i can't find anything that says how many
pedestrians have been injured
by these speed limits i can find
information on
um accidents
um in this in the cbd area and stuff but
um
that doesn't it's there's no breakdown
of whether it's been a person that's
been hit
um so i'm
yeah i'm at a loss as to why this should
be implemented at all
i'm trying to follow um the government
directive which i think putting things
down to 80 k's
and uh in a 100k zone is just it's just
a backward idea shona can i just
interrupt there um look council is
required to
conduct a speed review
every so many years it has to
so
the fact that the government is doing
its
thing at the moment
is is
is helpful but the council is required
and when it doesn't speed review this is
the opportunity that we look at things
okay and then we go out for consultation
so it happens every so many years
okay cool yeah sorry i'm not aware of
that so anyway like i said i'm usually
this sort of thing so yeah so anyway
that's i think that's all i can really
sort of say to it really okay we've got
time for questions
uh
any questions
no there are no questions so thank you
very much for your submission
okay thank you
right that goes now to
matthew milner
i think he's in person
just a little ahead of time
do you want to start the pvp
wash your mouth out
if you need to go you need to go
oh
that's
okay are we
come on
i think it's
might i just make a
a quick comment yeah
um
i just wonder because of what the last
submitter said at the start of her
submission
whether it would be
worthwhile for council's communication
team to perhaps write to her and explain
that no pre decisions are made
before
we have actually had the consideration
perhaps she indicated that this was a
totally new process to her i just wonder
whether it might be useful
to communicate and just let her know the
actual process of the submissions and
the consideration
after the hearings etc i just wouldn't
like
i wouldn't like her to have the
impression that there was any possible
pre-decision
well she's not the first person to
mention it there's a couple of people
who through their submissions have said
that they believe that council
thinks it's a foregone conclusion i
think when we get to the point of
deliberating in a couple of weeks that's
when we probably need to start that
process off with being clear
mr chair i would remind all members that
submitters are communicated with as to
the
decision that is finally made
and perhaps the
best way to do that to treat all
submitters
who may have thought it but not said it
who may have said it or for whom it may
not have occurred to or might not be
aware of the process perhaps we should
take extra care this time to set out the
process
that council goes through and the
reasons for that process
that that would be that would be useful
it certainly has come through and that
submitter was the
most obvious example of it that perhaps
there are a number of
new submitters
not aware of the process this time
and my observation would be that live
streaming and zoom can be very helpful
but the potential to pick something up
incorrectly yes
and um masks also make life difficult
i thought what she said that was that
she actually heard those words spoken
and wrote them down
that's what i
[Music]
i think it was the chair-headed
knowledge that there was some wider
issues being thrown up and that that was
noted that that's what i picked up
we've got someone now
i'll show you my thing look at that she
might just hear something
do you want to just daniel would you
like to just cut streaming for a second
thank you
like to reconvene the meeting
you sit down
okay brendan
you might want to stand up yeah
you have that choice we may not hear you
that's good to know
okay
are we straight into it are we we're
straight into it
yeah we had a cancellation from the
submitter before you so all right that's
why we're a fraction early
no problem
have you got my submission in front here
there yes yes
well have you has anybody got any
questions for me to start with
uh is it being read normally if you do
want to say something normal process is
you can speak summarize it and then we
ask some questions okay then so
i live in the uh emperor subdivision
um
and i just thought this is a good
opportunity to
um
come and
talk to you all and
um
sort of express
our opinions and such
um because i know this is the correct
process for doing things so
obviously we're talking about the speed
limits
and uh so yeah like i saw this is a
great opportunity so i just want to
start with um
the speed limit on on retreat road which
is the main access
into inverary at the moment and of
course you know retreat road doubles as
the main x is for a lot of people that
live
in uh maquiva road you know right
through to the outskirts of morris bush
so it is quite a busy wee
uh street so basically everybody that's
um heading home
along queens drive
out to morris bush
they all shoot through
retreat road which
which is quite a um
[Music]
you know it's a good way shortcut and
it's obviously the main way to go
everyone in this room has potentially
used retreat road so they know what i'm
talking about
and it does get quite busy so
as a residence
um
we just find that
80k along retreat road is
most certainly too quick
we need to bear in mind the amount of
new houses that are
being built in that area now and that
have been built there you know in the
past 10 years it has slowly steadily
been increasing
you know retreat road was
initially designed
as a as a farm access road i guess back
in the 50s and 60s
when there were predominantly farms in
that part of town and
i've had
you know dealings with retreat road you
know since since the 80s we had friends
that lived on retreat right in the 80s
and it was it was the same thing
as as what it is now
but i would say with you know
potentially 10 times the amount of
people living
out in that area so we we do feel
retreat road needs to
be upgraded and be widened
um
so
the other thing i want to mention with
treat road is like i think it could
it could also have a footpath
um you know we've obviously got donovan
park right beside
right beside it so we've got a footpath
from the south entrance of donovan park
but there's no way
of accessing the north side of donovan
park from retreat road and
and like i say with the amount of houses
being built in that part of town now it
would be a great wee feature for
invercargill and all the residents in
that area to be able to walk from the
south side of donovan park
along retreat road and
um along mciver road and then back into
the north side of donovan park it's just
it's a footpath and and as we know
in communities
um with families people walking
exercising
it's just the the logical next step that
it is
there is a footpath there at the moment
um i believe
the developer of
in bururi was was made to put that
footpath in as part of his
development but it really is
quite substandard it's it's it's untidy
it's always covered with gravel and
weeds
uh and it really isn't quite fit for
purpose it would just be nice to see
council
uh add to that in in and add to the
the you know the infrastructure in the
area for for the residents and it's not
it's not only people walking it's people
biking as well okay so just to get to
get back on to speed your key
thing is the speed reduction on yeah
yeah sorry
yeah i i would like to see
um
sorry right at 50k right 50k now yeah
yeah because it's not a rural road
anymore it's a
it's an incredible street yep
um
so that's
that's why we rent on retreat road
okay i can um and all right you wanna
yeah yeah and now i'll just like to get
on to the embroidery subdivision okay
yeah
um
so
obviously inferior is growing
all the time there's
it'd be a dozen new houses being built
out there at the moment and there's
families
popping up out there left right and
center
that the current speed limit in
inverurie at the moment is 80k and air
um which is yeah
you you walk along retreat road you know
after you i went for a walk last night
when i got home from work at 5 30 with
the dogs and someone come in they do an
80k and air it's just like
it's like a bullet going past you you
know there's there's no road markings on
the road
there's
you know there's a footpath on one side
and
there's kids on bikes and
and the speed limit is 80 kilometers in
air and this is invaria you're talking
about yes in the estate yes yeah it's
currently eight kilometers in there
because
it's 80 kilometers in there on retreat
road
and and um as you turn off a treat road
onto inverurie there is no sign
um to reduce the speed so legally it is
80. right so there is no right so so
i
obviously um that that's going to change
because what we need to bear in mind is
retreat right um inverary subdivision is
going to be linked through to bainfield
road
in in the very near future and it will
therefore become a loop between the two
roads
it's simply going to be
create a racing track because it's nice
smooth seal
it's got a couple of nice corners that
we all enjoy going around corners a wee
bit quicker for on motorbikes or in cars
or whatever and it's just it's simply a
bit dangerous so i i feel um in the
future
uh the embroidery subdivision should be
40 kilometers in there
and that's and that's based on my
dealings with new homes that are being
built
in
in the central otago new subdivisions
all around
aerotown wanaka queenstown all those new
subdivisions um when you turn off the
main road you're obviously designed for
residents only
and and it's 40 kilometers in air when
you drive into those areas and and i
truly truly think that um and ferrari
should be 40 kilometers in there
just just as a comment chair having said
on the consenting panel for that it
might pay for someone to revisit the
terms of the consent
because that may have been a part of it
but it just hasn't been the second one
today so that's noted that that is noted
um
so
are you
ready for questions now
or
still
yeah no i'm certainly ready for
questions but i just got i've just got
one other thing that i'd like to offer
as a solution
um
because i'm not all about problems i
will offer solutions
so
we we have knees road which is the next
road over from retreat road and and it
actually knees road does exactly the
same thing as retreat road so it links
bainfield road to mciver road
now now bearing in mind retreat road is
so busy because
everybody that lives in morris bush
comes along queens drive and heads home
through retreat right off of knees road
was was sealed
that would also provide an important
link to all those people that live out
near morris bush and and they would then
have the option of not only going down
retreat road they could also go down
knees road which as as invercargill
grows
things are grown in that area
um i just see knees road as being the
logical next step to to seal
and
and and become better access for all the
new houses that are being built in in
that part of town so that's
just just just the way solution that i'd
like to offer
okay
um questions council
ms cook
um
i notice in your submission
that you've talked about reductions um
positively
right through basically um
is it
your view that it's a safety issue or is
it a
quality of life issue or is it a
both of those things or
because you've you've commented
positively
to all of those things
i th yeah i
i i think it's both it's definitely it's
a safety issue and it's a quality of
life issue and i think
the the way the direction where we're
all heading is
is you know we need to to offer as a
city we need to offer alternative modes
of transport so we've got to be looking
positively at
walking we've got to be looking
positively at biking we've got to be
looking positively at
um public transport
so
you know having having cars roaring up
and down the road
is
almost you know it's
it's not it's not the way forward is it
we need to we need to be offering other
modes of transport where and i guess the
two main major transport that that are
most common in invercargill are walking
and biking
um
so
you know if we reduce the speed
widen the roads
off a bit of footpaths
have
you know cycle lanes which we've you
know by the way made a a great job of so
far
but you know there are a few of these
other areas that have grown a lot in the
last couple of years that
you know we could look at cycle lanes
and better footpaths and you know
slightly wider roads so a family can
walk down there without being that point
at that point by truck so no i think i
think a wee bit of boat thank you
okay further questions
thank you very much
brendan
thank
still blown away by that and brewery
no no speed site
yeah yeah yeah
80k is yeah no no i assume yeah that's
right there's no sign
yeah yeah even even on retreat road when
you see a car going 80k and air down
there
you know you you look at it and you
almost you know your immediate thinking
is that that car is speeding
because you know the right case when i
lived there it was no wider yeah yeah
yeah
right there was another car coming yeah
yeah okay so no we can't we can't
discuss this further but uh no it's very
interesting points you've raised
okay thanks very much for the
opportunity
excellent
so there's no reduction
and we're going to give them
zooming in too
are they zooming
in
okay
almost the same
um
and neither of them
um
[Music]
on wednesday
yes
well we were meant to get it down here
[Music]
who just said
oh
really doesn't see it that way
yeah sunday
um
i might swap with you if i may and i'll
just go and sort out about something
related to them
for a long time
scottish
[Laughter]
is
um
[Music]
council
is
you can dream
right
welcome to the youth council
um first can i get your
um
to introduce yourself
uh
and then i'll get you to start all right
no worries yeah and you may take your
mask off
only if you want to yeah
okay
uh good afternoon councillors
um your worship and mano finawa um my
name is ryan frost and i will be
speaking to you on behalf of the
invercargill city youth council uh with
karyana simpson and jonty robertson
do we have this slideshow
invitation
okay very good
right just
as it comes up
um just for your information the issues
and points
on this presentation are in reference to
the speed review consultation document
and its questions much of the rash now
behind our stance for each issue
is similar so we may outline some of the
particular reasoning for each issue but
just know that these reasons do apply
for most of the points in our
presentation
number one issue one
point three youth council does not
support the proposed principle of
reducing speeds on urban roads over time
to 40 kilometers
one of the first reasons for our
rationale for this is
the negative influences this would have
on the cost of living
as you may know effectively everything
in this country gets trapped around on
our roads this includes
food and fuel and many other important
consumer goods
by decreasing the speeds that vehicles
can travel at you increase its travel
time which also has impacts on the wage
cost for transport companies
as well as increase
as well as decreasing speed limit from
50 kilometers to 40 kilometers in town
also has a negative
impact on the fuel consumption of
vehicles over that journey and i will
touch more on this on a graph in the
next slide
and an increase in fuel consumption is
also
an added cost for transport companies
and everyone driving in town but it also
has detrimental effects to the
environment
another reason for this is the negative
impacts this has on emergency service
response time uh john t will cover this
more later
now for the increase in carbon emissions
that is caused by an increase
in the fuel consumption uh as you can
possibly see on the slide
on this on this graph here
um that fuel consumption varies with the
average speed of a journey
and
the optimal typically the optimal range
for a
car's journey is between 60 kilometers
and 80 kilometers
so that's the optimal range for a
vehicle to travel at while there is a
decrease
in fuel consumption from 100 kilometers
to 80 kilometers there is in fact an
increase in fuel consumption when you
reduce the average speed from 50 to
kilometers down to 40 kilometers so
therefore it is less efficient more fuel
is consumed which costs more and more
carbon emissions are output by a vehicle
issue one
point 0.4 use council does not support
the supposed principle to reduce speeds
on many rural roads over time to 60
kilometers
um
the rationale behind this is similar to
the emergency response time which jaunty
will cover but we also don't believe it
is necessary and will aid in achieving
its desired outcomes of significantly
reducing the road toll
compared to other methods
for example driver education which we
believe is something that should take
more of a central row uh role in
attempting to reduce the road toll
um
really for a lot of these um
[Music]
proposals of reducing the speed limit uh
we feel that the
the costs outweigh um any possible
benefits that will be gained
by reducing uh the speed
limit uh the road toll is 62 less than
its all-time peak in 1972
and there are significantly more cars on
the road today than what they were in
1972
while youth council does oppose most of
the proposed changes in the speed review
we are strongly in support
of changes to variables
the implementation of variable speed
limits
around school zones
um and we believe that these changes
should be introduced as quick as
possible so the positive benefits of
changes to variable speed limits around
schools
will be seen quicker and katyana will
now speak more on this
um
the youth council does support
the proposal to reduce speeds outside
school zones though we believe the
variable speed limits
should be introduced at 20 kilometers on
rural and urban schools
there are buses in and around schools
anyway meaning that 20 kilometers is
less confusing and more more consistent
when driving around a school and school
children
also a 20 kilometre speed limit will
reduce danger to young students who are
not as mature and are a lot more
vulnerable around roads and we see this
when
a school bus is 20 kilometers therefore
that is what has been produced as the
appropriate speed limit to travel around
school children therefore it should be
introduced
around school zones as well and
now
issue
3.8
youth council does not support council's
proposal to reduce speed limits
to 30 kilometers an hour in suburban
shopping streets
windsor and south city as examples
this is because
again it has the negative effect on
emergency services response times with
which jaunty will expand on soon
it also
we reject the idea that reducing speed
limits in the cbd and shopping centers
will make shopping more attractive as
suggested in the consultation document
people walk along the footpath not the
road and should cross at lights or
pedestrian crossings and we
reject the idea that
this will create more foot traffic and
higher density of people in the shopping
areas
we would also like to propose that the
section of isk street in question be
turned into a pedestrian zone
instead of reducing the speed to 10
kilometers we think that this would be a
more appropriate option and would have
and create a very good environment for
that section of
the city especially with the new mall
coming in
yeah
now i'd like to introduce jonty to
expand on the emergency services
so decreasing the speed will directly
affect the response time of emergency
service and it is a well-known fact that
a minute two minutes three minutes even
will have an impact on the result of a
life in an emergency whether that be a
fire or an ambulance or anything like
that
the fire service have a legal defense of
25 kilometers per hour over the speed
limit
which means if we reduce the speeds to
40 it will they will be able to go
sorry 65 over the speed limit 65
kilometers per hour and 30 means 55
this will result in more congestion
especially around the al's road
roundabout
this will prove
to slow
this will prove to
increase the emergency service response
time as they will have a harder time
getting around traffic and
but thus have a impact on the result of
a life
now over to ryan
issue 4.9 unsealed in rural roads youth
council does not support the proposal to
make changes to the speed limits for the
listed narrow
and gravel roads on the consultation
document
the reasons for this is that youth
council fundamentally believes that
drivers should drive to the conditions
uh with rural and mini gravel roads the
optimal um and the appropriate speed to
travel um greatly varies compared to the
likes of a sealed road
simply because the factors of the
vehicle you're driving
is a lot more important
as well as the weather
and
this current state of a gravel road
while it's probably not appropriate to
drive down 100 kilometers
down a gravel road depending on the
vehicle you're driving
if you're driving as if it's a good day
and you're driving a truck
you reasonably are going to be able to
drive significantly faster than 60
kilometers however if you were driving
quite a
a car that was quite low to the ground
uh then the driver would probably
then it would be only appropriate to
drive it say 60 kilometers but if you're
driving a vehicle that's suited to the
um roads
um and the weather is fine and the road
is in reasonable condition there is no
reason why you shouldn't be able to
drive faster than 60 kilometers
now onto the roading and traffic bylaw
um for point one of the question
removing the one-way section of don
street to be a two-way uh street once
upgrades have been completed a youth
council's response to this question is
that we believe keeping don street uh
one way would be the best option rather
than just having two rather narrow lanes
for question number two regarding the
amendment to the rural vehicles crossing
um amendment youth council does not have
an opinion on this issue
uh and for question number three
around um
the amendment to access to the urity
beach for vehicles uh youth council
welcomes clear information on the
circumstances when council may close
arity beach however youth council
believes that the beach
should be
keeping the beach open to a public the
public should be a priority um
ultimately we believe the public should
be responsible for ensuring the vehicle
does not get stuck in the entrance way
and if it does they should be
responsible for freeing it
to summarize you youth council
fundamentally believes that drivers
should drive to the conditions
when conditions on roads warrant drivers
to drive at slash speeds most drivers
will in the cases where drivers don't it
can be put down to poor driver education
or basic
belligerence on the driver's behalf
driving education is something that
youth council believes should be
improved and should take a central part
in making our roads safer we recognize
that this is primarily a role for the
central government to do however council
could also attempt to do something if it
felt as though it was in its power
in the case of drivers belligerence
these drivers would unlikely be unlikely
to follow the new limits any speed
limits anyway so therefore the proposed
changes would not solve
the issue news council believes that the
prosecution of drivers for reckless or
dangerous driving should be more
commonplace and achieving convictions
for reckless driving or dangerous
driving should be easier however this is
of course a more sovereign role for
central government um thank you for have
hearing us missions are there any
questions okay thank you very much
questions councillor clark
yeah thank you uh just one question
around the
uh speed zones around the schools i
think you said that
you thought it should be k's
and so what i want to know is is that
something you have on all day every day
including weekends
no it would be a variable speed limit
introduced uh only during pickup and
drop off times
so most likely for most schools that
would be within the hours of uh
7 7 30 to possibly 8 30
it depends on the school but no the the
speed limit would only be in place
during the time that children are
entering school and exiting school um
during most of the school's operating
hours it also would not be in place as
school students are not meant to leave
school property to begin with
thank you for that good
any other questions counselor thank you
cheer um just in coming to your
conclusions are you aware of the number
of road fatalities there are due to
excessive speed did you consider that
um
yes we have but we believe that as long
as people drive on the roads there is
always going to be
um road fatalities due to someone not
driving the appropriate speed at the
appropriate time
um
we think it would be more effective if
drivers
knew how to drive
at an appropriate speed
um
where it's most
important
for example the city centers
um we mentioned that we don't believe
that they should
the speed limit should be reduced to 50
um
down to 30 kilometers because
during certain times the speed limit is
the maximum speed you should be able to
drive in optimal conditions uh which is
reasonable but if you know if the city
centre is very busy um you're not going
to be able to go down there at 50
kilometers you will drivers will have to
slow down and if a driver weren't to
slow down and was end up killing someone
because they were not driving
responsibly well that would be
reckless driving a prosecutable offense
sorry i just needed to clarify that i
was
more concerned around the rural roads
and particular rural raids because
that's the stats but just further to
that did you have any correspondence or
discussion with the emergency service
about how they interact and react
no we have not okay thank you
councillor craic
oh thank you mr chair um firstly uh i'd
like to commend you for your fantastic
submission thank you very much for
coming along and the powerpoint and
everything um so i think i'm picking up
from what you're saying there ryan that
you would
sooner see rather than a reduction in
speed limit um
significantly heavier enforcement
uh as well as driving education yes we
think there are better ways to improve
or to decrease
the road toll and safety outcomes on a
road then reducing the speed limit
when reducing the speed limit has
many trade-offs
well i guess it is true that
the number of deaths on the roads
would be
possibly less
we don't think that these would outweigh
the significant disadvantages of
decreasing the speed limits thank you
let's go
um firstly thank you for your submission
and for it being so well articulated
um
i'm a little bit interested in the
contradiction between your willingness
to have a 20 kilometer
an hour speed zone around a school
or schools in general um but not in um
similarly busy areas psych shopping
centres given that one of the shopping
centres concerned
is within a school zone and has
significant issues with
speed had you considered that when you
were considering the school you know
around schools is fine around shopping
centers isn't but shopping centres and
schools and sometimes sit side by side
well in the event that a shopping center
and a school sits side by side um i
imagine that that shopping center would
be included in the variable speed limit
strip for schools but specifically the
reason why we think that variable speed
limits should be introduced around
schools is that
school children and young children
they don't know
how to be responsible around the road
as much as what an adult in a shopping
centre would and most young children um
you know in town and in the shopping
centers say on the weekends would be
with parents and then parents who are
more
aware of how to
responsibly act around the road would
look after the children um
yeah so the around schools that
specifically centered around the idea
that school children
are not
um
as capable of ensuring their safety
around the road
is that it says
thank you for your thoughts
okay
um
thank you for that that was a very good
science-based evidence-based mission
there was
very good and when you talked about
driver
driver education i saw no better example
than yesterday morning driving to work
in that misty fog
very poor visibility and the amount of
cars
that had no lights on and it just you
wonder what goes through their mind when
they jump in their car and they can't
see other cars what are they thinking
you know
um
so yeah that was a very good submission
thank you very much thank you thank you
um there is nothing further on this
agenda so i now declared
there's a series of recommendations oh
recommendation
thank you so i'm happy to move
i'll just go to that i think i'll second
those
this is receiving the report receiving
the submissions the late submissions
hearing from the submitters here we go
the recommendations one two three
and four
and five
so do you want to move those as a group
yes
thank you dive secondary councillor sofa
i'll put that motion all those in favor
all right
against that is carried thank you
meaning is now closed